MonkaW
Irgendwo hab ich ein
USB-C
Zu normalem USB
Und irgendwie
Ich find's einfach nicht
Weil es wär ganz gut
Könnte ich da
Ich hab hier so ne Steckdosenleiste, die hat noch 4 freie USB
Stecker
Und da könnte ich die auch noch mit benutzen
KA
Wo ich das hab
Dankeschön
Hast du schon das Windows-Video von Morpheus gesehen?
Welches? Welches denn?
Weiß nicht, vielleicht haben wir das sogar auf
Bin mir doch gar nicht sicher, ich hab ja ein paar Sachen hier
Guck mal, guck mal doch mal
So ne
Was, was?
Goodbye Windows, Chat-Kontrolle nur schlimmer
Microsofts neuer Service-Vertrag
Ja das hab ich
Das hab ich nicht geguckt
Aber ich hab das gelesen, ich hab da irgendwo was drüber gelesen
Das Microsoft jetzt irgendwie noch
Ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen
Aber ich hab was drüber gelesen
Letztendlich wird's wahrscheinlich
Keinen wirklich jucken, der es benutzt
Und sie werden es einfach alle weiter benutzen
Ein Frexor
Ich muss sagen, wird besser
Mir tun die Beine heute gar nicht mehr groß weh
Letztes Mal war viel anstrengender
Ein
Wurzel-Zapp
Der Scam-Train
Ich hab
Gesehen, Bezos will gar nicht mehr ins Weltall
Für was, für was
Scam-Train twitcht denn jetzt weiter
Einfach nur noch Geld
Also ich mein, Weltall wär nice gewesen
Aber
Chat, wenn ihr die Chance hättet
Das war meine erste Frage, ja
Wenn ihr die Chance hättet, ins Weltall
Zu fliegen
Sei es jetzt irgendwie so als Weltall-Tourist so
Irgendwie keine Ahnung
Ein Tag
Auf die
Internationale Raumstation und zurück
Ist egal, ob das jetzt realistisch ist, dass das geht
Oder nicht, aber gehen wir mal von aus
Ihr könntet das machen, würdet ihr das machen oder nicht
Also würdet ihr
Euch in eine Rakete setzen, ins Weltall
Schießen lassen und
Dann da irgendwie einen Tag rumfliegen
Und dann wieder zurück
Also wir gehen davon aus, hin und rück
Ist gesichert, ja
Natürlich die Gefahren, die es birgt, ja
Ihr werdet auf jeden Fall wieder zurückgeflogen
Würdet ihr das machen?
Ich wahrscheinlich auch
Ich würds wahrscheinlich auch machen
Mit Bitcoin-Logo
Ich dachte
Dogi-Coin
Mal kurz anschauen
Na gut, man darf ja nicht vergessen
Ganz ungefährlich ist es ja nur auch
Wiederum nicht, sich in so eine Rakete zu setzen
Und
Ganz ungefährlich ist es ja auch nicht
Sich in so eine Rakete zu setzen
Vor allem auch wieder zu landen
Aber ich würd das wahrscheinlich
Trotzdem machen
Zumal
Generell ist es ja relativ safe
Die letzten Jahre über, es passiert ja kaum was
Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass es so ungefährlich ist
Weil wenn da irgendwas schief geht
Hast du zu 99% immer gelitten
Eigentlich
Da ist nicht so viel, was du machen kannst
Kannst du nicht mal in den Flieger steigen?
Ich glaube die
Kräfte
Und Belastung in der Rakete
Sind zwar sicherlich höher als bei
So einem 0815-Verkehrsflieger
Aber ich glaube die sind
Ganz andere als in einem Flieger
Ein Flieger ist ja eher
Quasi
Horizontal mit ein bisschen auf und ab
Gefallen zwischendurch
Rakete ist im Prinzip ja fast nur
Fast nur vertikal
Wo es sich halt nach hinten drückt
Und halt auch ordentlich durchschüttelt
Keine Ahnung also
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch machen
Das ist jetzt ein Vergleich
Da wollte ich eigentlich nicht drauf raus
Die Chancen stehen ja ganz gut
Dass man es überlebt
Also wenn die Chancen so schlecht ständen wie
Beispielsweise wo sie das alles erprobt haben
Mit
Wie baut man so eine Rakete und sowas
Dann würde ich da auch nicht mitfliegen
Aber in der heutigen Zeit
Also wenn ich die Chance hätte würde ich es wahrscheinlich machen
Ja du bist doch nicht alleine
Es gibt ja viele Leute die haben Angst vor Flugzeugen
Es gibt ja Leute die haben Angst vor Fahrzeugen und sowas
Das kann man ja nicht immer so richtig rational bekunden
In Fahrstühlen passiert auch nichts
Also ich glaube
Es sterben nicht mal eine Person im Jahr
An Fahrstuhldingern
Sondern irgendwie 0,0
Irgendwas
Und dann meistens
Doch nicht mal durch Fahrstuhlsachen selber
Sondern durch irgendwelche umstehenden
Liegenden Sachen
Also da passiert ja eigentlich nichts
Aber man kann das
Das ist genauso wie wenn Leute Angst
Sagen wir mal haben vor
Spinnen oder so
Bei uns zumindest in unseren Breitengraden
Die tun ja auch nichts
Aber ich mag Spinnen auch nicht
Also das kann man nicht so wirklich
Wirklich erklären oftmals
Aber es ist halt so
Also eine Sache habe ich auch letztens gemerkt
Wir müssen übrigens gleich nochmal eine Runde
Shit Hub Trending wieder gucken
Eine Sache habe ich bei mir gemerkt
Also ich habe nicht wirklich
Höhenangst aber
Mir wird es ein bisschen
Also ich
Ich halte mich doch schon ein bisschen mehr am Geländer fest
Letztens bin ich mal
Auf einem meiner Wanderausflüge
Auf so einen Turm hochgelaufen
Das war kein super hoher Turm
Das war jetzt nicht Frankfurt
150 Stockwerke oder sonst was
Das war einfach so ein ganz normaler
Alter Turm wo man hoch konnte
Aber dementsprechend war der halt auch
Ungesichert
Wobei
Ich kann euch das eigentlich mal zeigen
Den Turm
Falls es da von Bilder gibt
Ja genau
Da ist ein Turm
Hat Google nicht eigentlich Fotos und sowas normalerweise
Also hier ist ein Restaurant
Aber hier gibt es eigentlich
Hier ist kein Turm
Hecke
Warum ist das so schlecht auf einmal
Wir gehen mal direkt auf Google Maps
Zumindest
Da ist ein
Ja aus irgendwo
Also normalerweise ist hier ein Turm wo man rauf
Da hat doch Google
Da hat doch Google immer Bilder
Ähm
Warum sieht man den Turm hier nicht
Ach doch hier ist der Turm
Ok der Turm sieht aus Satelliten
Perspektive gar nichts
Aber man sieht hier schon am Schatten das ist relativ hoch
Da kann man so ein halbes Jahr lang
Ungefähr rauf
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja da
Hier sieht man das doch
Ja das Teil
Da bin ich letztens rauf
Da ist nur
Hier nur die untere Aussicht
Untere Aussicht war quasi 21 Meter hoch
Das hält sich echt in Grenzen
Im Vergleich zu irgendwelchen Gebäuden in Frankfurt oder so
Aber
Ist mir aufgefallen wenn man da raus geht
Irgendwie habe ich mich doch
Erstaunlich erstaunlich fest
Irgendwie am Geländer gehalten
Das Geländer
Sieht hier vielleicht hoch aus
Aber das Geländer geht im Prinzip auch nur bis zum Bauch
Also wenn man will
Könnte man da ohne Probleme runterfallen
Und das hatte ich früher auch nicht
Da war es mir schon ein bisschen komisch
Ehrlich gesagt
Wenn man da oben runter geguckt hat
Es ändert sich da auch
Mit der Zeit so ein bisschen was dran
Deswegen muss man sich keine Gedanken machen
Wenn man Angst hat vor Flugzeugen
Fahrstühlen sonst was
Das kann ich nicht so richtig rational erklären
Die Chance dass ich da runtergefallen wäre sind auch
Nähern sich null
Aber
Es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen Gewöhnungssache
Wenn ich da jetzt jeden Tag hochlaufen würde
Würde es mich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr schocken
Was mich im Gegensatz nicht schockt ist
Gibt ja in Frankfurt auch ein paar Hochhäuser
Wo man
Raus kann und runter gucken kann
Und
Oder gibt ja auch welche
Gibt da sogar Türme
Das hat mich alles nicht geschockt
Auch bei uns in der alten Firma
Aufs Gebäude obendrauf, aufs Dach
Und da runter gucken
Auch nicht, irgendwie komisch
Manchmal schockt es einen nicht, manchmal schon
Hat bestimmt noch was mit den Umständen zu tun
Und viel ist Gewöhnungssache
Ich glaube die meisten Menschen sterben nicht zu Hause
Ich glaube die sterben im Krankenhaus
Ich glaube statistisch gesehen
Müsste man jetzt ja quasi sagen
Das Krankenhaus ist der gefährlichste Ort
Aber da sieht man, dass man mit sowas
Wunderbar Ursache und Wirkung umdrehen kann
Weil den meisten Leuten geht es schlecht
Deswegen sind sie im Krankenhaus
Das heißt nicht, dass es den Leuten im Krankenhaus
Durchs Krankenhaus schlecht geht
Aber wenn man sich mal rein die Zahlen anguckt
Die meisten Leute sterben im Krankenhaus
Wird man sagen
Krankenhaus ist super gefährlich
Okay, seit
Multiresistenten Keimen und man kann sich Corona
Und alles einfangen ins Krankenhaus
Wahrscheinlich echt nicht so, ne
Sonst sind halt viele Krankenleute
Im Krankenhaus und deswegen
Also in Frankfurt gibt es ein paar
Aussichtsplattformen, die haben so Glasböden
Aber glücklicherweise
Habe ich dort noch keins gesehen
Zumindest wo ich gewesen bin
Die so komplett durchsichtiges Glas haben
Es war immer gut als Glasboden zu erkennen
Es gibt ja
So Aussichtsplattformen, die haben
Glasboden, der extra
Gefühlt so gemacht ist, dass du das Glas nicht siehst
Und das ist dann schon ein bisschen
Etwas anderes
Gibt dann auch Leute, die müssen darauf rumspringen
So nach dem Motto, hey vielleicht kriege ich es
Kaputt und Leute, die eh schon Schiss haben
Kriegen es dann immer mit der Angst zu tun
Aber vieles kann man
Nicht so wirklich rational erklären, warum man
Da Schiss vor hat
Ich kriege mein eigenes Video
Empfohlen
Muss ich mal anklicken für ein bisschen Viewtime
Wobei wenn es danach
Wenn es nach Viewtime geht, müsste ich es eigentlich
Laufen lassen, weil wenn man es nicht laufen lässt
Dann ist es ja schlechte Viewtime
Ich lasse einfach mal mein eigenes Video kurz laufen, easy
Gestern war der tausendste Stream im Archiv
Pog
Dazu kann man ja nur sagen
Und natürlich
Wusstet ihr eigentlich
Funfact am Rand, das hat wahrscheinlich von euch
Keiner wirklich mitgekriegt, außer dem Modgis
Das Archiv
Ist jetzt nur noch
Wobei da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen
Das läuft ja auf einer eigenen Kiste
Da kümmert sich
Unser Ober-Cute-Mod
Drum, höchstpersönlich
Und der MaxBauer hat die Software
Darauf gebaut, die darauf läuft
Also nicht ich, sondern der Max
Und
Letztens hat er mich angeschrieben
Der Ober-Cute-Mod persönlich
Wir müssen
DNS-Einträge ändern, weil
Der Archiv-Server hat sich geändert
Ja okay, gib halt
Neue IP-Adresse her, ich trage schnell ein
Und dann meinte er so zu mir
Ja Max, aber das Server ist nur noch IPv6
Erreichbar
Und jetzt kommt der Hit
Wir haben jetzt ein eigenes
BGP-Netz
Aber ich mein
Entschuldigung, was?
Warum haben wir für den Archiv-Server
Ein eigenes, das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn
Ja
Und dann kam irgendwie raus, dass
Keine Ahnung, was die da getrieben haben
Er und ein Kumpel haben sich irgendwie
Als Provider angemeldet und haben jetzt ein eigenes
IPv6
BGP-Netz und da steht
Der Archiv-Server drin
Also leichter
Overkill
Das einzige Problem daran ist
Jetzt, dass das Archiv
Eigentlich nicht mehr per
IPv4 erreichbar ist
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt einen Cloudflare-Tunnel davor
Der IPv4
Auf IPv6 macht
Damit das überhaupt noch funktioniert
Aber ich mein
Es scheint ja alles zu funktionieren
Suchen wir mal Keckel
Keckel
Gucken wir mal, ob die
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert
Wenn man da draufklickt
Müsste ich jetzt gleich Keckel sagen
Keckel
L
Ja, hat
L4
Name
Keckel
Funktioniert
Also muss ich sagen, das Indexen
Ist schon wirklich nice
Sehr based
Oh, der Chat war kurzzeitig kaputt
Alter, ich bin so müde
Immer noch
Meta-Quest 3, das habe ich glaube ich
Sogar schon offen hier, aber das gucken wir uns mal an
Weil nach dem initialen
Hype vor 4-5 Jahren
Mit der Oculus Rift
Es könnte sogar schon 6 Jahre her gewesen sein
Wo alle gesagt haben, ja diesmal
Aber diesmal wirklich
Virtual Reality, diesmal ist es echt soweit
Hat sich da nicht allzu viel getan?
Oh, Leute
Das
Das Arbeitsamt erzählt uns was über Physi
Das muss ich mir angucken
Mal gucken
Wie realitätsnah das ist, was die uns erzählen
Wahrscheinlich erzählen die uns wieder
Du wechselst Monitore und tauschst Druckerpatronen
Oje, das wird was
Fachinformatiker
Innen, der Fachrichtung Systemintegration
Realisierung, Kundenspitze
Bla bla bla
Allerdings schreckt mich die softwarebezogene Seite ab
Warum?
Ich hatte im Abitur erste Kontakte mit MySQL
Ja gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran
Weil der Unterricht gesackt hat
Ja gut, ich meine, es kann natürlich auch sein, dass es nichts für ihn ist
Aber so rein die
Hardwareseite ohne irgendwas
Wird halt sehr schwierig, weil da läuft halt
Was drauf
Ist ja für irgendeinen Zweck da
Ich muss sagen
Ich hab die letzten Jahre über
Immer weniger Interesse an der reinen
Hardware gehabt
Mehr an Softwareseite
Auch an Softwareentwicklung
Ich bastel natürlich immer noch gerne
Aber
Wir haben ja auch Microcontroller gebastelt
Wobei es da auch hauptsächlich darum ging, eigene Firmen
zu bauen
Irgendwelche Smart
Sachen umgebaut
Aber so richtig mit PC-Hardware
Da ist bei mir die Faszination
Ehrlich gesagt schon ein bisschen raus
Gibt Leute, da geht das genau umgedreht
Ich glaube der Bauer, der ist da immer noch
Voll dabei, was PC-Hardware angeht
Ja gut, der ist ein paar Jahre jünger als ich glaube ich
Aber wenn man sich den Channel anguckt
Der findet natürlich, PC-Hardware geht da immer noch voll drauf ab
So als
Übertaktungsspezialist
Aber es ändert sich oftmals ja auch
Ein bisschen, was einen so interessiert
Mit den Jahren
Früher fand ich PC-Hardware mega spannend
Ich hatte auch bei mir damals
Im Kinderzimmer noch
Uralte Hardware rumliegen
Die hat sich gestapelt, ich habe nichts weggeschmissen
Ich hatte da teilweise
Sachen, irgendwie diese super fetten
10 Megabyte
Festplatten hatte ich noch, die waren damals schon
Outdated
Ich glaube eine Sache habe ich beim Umzug mitgenommen
Warum auch immer, weiß ich nicht
Und die habe ich einfach noch nie weggeschmissen
Ich glaube ich habe noch
Eine Nvidia
Geforce 3 oder irgendwie sowas
Im Schrank liegen, warum, ich weiß es nicht
Aber ich interessiere mich aktuell
Nur für PC-Hardware
Wenn ich mir einen neuen PC kaufen will
Dazwischen verfolge ich das gar nicht mehr
Also ich könnte euch jetzt
Legit nicht sagen, was die schnellste
CPU fürs Gaming ist und ich könnte
Euch auch nicht sagen
Wie die aktuellen Top Intel
CPUs heißen oder Top AMD CPUs
Ich könnte raten, ich vermute mal
Bei Intel
Ist das wahrscheinlich einen i9
Immer noch, weiß ich nicht
Ob es da mittlerweile nicht auch i11 oder i13
Oder sowas gibt
Also
Vermutlich
Vermutlich nicht, also wahrscheinlich ist es immer noch
Ein i9 und wahrscheinlich
Also ich habe einen 13.900
Ne, habe ich 13.900
K, das heißt wahrscheinlich
Wahrscheinlich ist es mittlerweile ein 14.900
K oder so, der aktuell ist, ich habe echt keine Ahnung
Und bei AMD und bei den Ryzen
Benahmungen blicke ich noch weniger durch
Wahrscheinlich sind wir jetzt was
Bei Ryzen 4
7.000
9.600 oder irgendwas
Ich blicke es nicht
Ich weiß da genau einmal drüber Bescheid
Nämlich wenn ich mir einen neuen PC
Kaufen will und letztes Jahr im Dezember
Wusste ich kurzzeitig darüber Bescheid
Hat mir einen neuen PC zusammengestellt
Gekauft und jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr drüber Bescheid
Warum visualisierst du die Videos nicht auf YouTube
Warum verlinkst du auf den? Die haben wir als Backup auch auf YouTube
Ja
Wir haben das auch als Backup auf YouTube
Also nicht bei mir auf dem Main Channel, weil
Monkatos und sowas
Soll davon nicht beeinflusst werden und ich betreibe den ja auch nicht
Es ist auf YouTube
Aber das im Archive ist viel viel
Nicer, weil das Archive halt
Sowas hier zum Beispiel hat
Wenn ich jetzt nach Arch Linux suchen will
Suche ich hier nach Arch Linux
Und da kann man sowohl den Titel des
Times durchsuchen, mega schnell, weil
Fiverr hat Fulltext Search
Sondern man kann auch das durchsuchen mit
Timestamp, was ich wann wo sage
Und das geht auf YouTube nicht
Das ist halt sehr Six Head Time
Das ganze läuft übrigens auf der Cloudkiste
Mit, also initial
Lief das auf der Cloudkiste glaube ich mit
3090 RTX
RTX 3090 oder 2
RTX 3090 Grafikern
Die haben das initiale Archive
Transcribed
War einfach zu anstrengend
Zu eklig aktuell zu halten
Ich schicke meine Hardware nirgends wohin, weil
Das ist mir viel zu anstrengend, da müsst ihr einpacken und
Irgendwo hinschicken, sagt mir nix
Aber ich werde mir nie Fertigsysteme kaufen
Selbst wenn es super Fertigsysteme gibt
Ich glaube das werde ich
PC wird immer selbst zusammengebaut
Diesmal war es ja auch schon hart an der
Grenze Leute, erinnert sich noch jemand
Chat, erinnert sich noch jemand
An die Haarrisse im Mainboard
Also das mein Rechner überhaupt funktioniert
Scheint ja schon laut Chat ein absolutes Wunder
Zu sein
Nach den ganzen Haarrissen im Mainboard
Ja genau hier gibt es einen Youtube Channel
Der Youtube Channel war aber auch schon mal gebannt
Weil
Toss Sachen, deswegen hat das mit meinem Main Channel
Auch nichts zu tun und ich betreibe das auch nicht
Das ist nur noch mal als Backup
Ja du findest es garantiert
Wenn du Arch by the way suchst
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob der by the way
Richtig transcribed, ja
Was macht er?
Kommt mal
In 867
Fällen hat er erkannt
Dass ich Arch oder Archstealungs
By the way sage
Ich glaube der checkt sogar
Das btw und by the way
Das ist das richtige Fiverr
Das ist das gleiche damit gemeint ist
Wie heißt die Archive Software?
Die heißt gar nicht
Das ist Wubblers Spezial Archive Software
Der durchsucht alles Gesagte
Ja
Wenn ich
Cute Chat Eieiei sage
Dann erkennt er das
Wie gesagt
Initial wurde das ganze transcribed
Auf einer Linux Kiste
Mit 2 RTX 3090
Mittlerweile weiß ich es gar nicht
Max worauf läuft denn das aktuell?
Ist das noch mit GPU Processing oder geht das
Jetzt ohne weil es immer nur Stream by Stream ist
Hast du dir die MW3 Beta
Angeschaut? Nein habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt
Kein Bock drauf
Ich muss sagen das Remake
Seit MW1
Ich rede jetzt nicht von Warzone von Multiplayer
Mir gefällt das Spielgefühl
Überhaupt nicht
Das ist so anstrengend
Und oftmals auch
Slowpace ist das falsche Wort
Man kann sich ja da schon bewegen
Es ist so anstrengend
Einfach nur
Und ich mag den
Gesamten Spielfluss nicht
Aktuell wird es auf einer 3080 transcribed
Byfair Time
Guck mit einer 3080 transcribed
Up Aim Heavy
Ja das trifft
Das ist das Wort was mir gefällt
Es ist sehr Up Aim Heavy
Das trifft es wirklich ganz gut
Das ist nicht Open Source
Das ist auch zusammen
Gesetzt aus unterschiedlichen
Ich glaube Max
Ich glaube es ist ein
Svelte Kit Frontend
Es ist
Ein Backend
Weiß ich gar nicht
Was es ist
Mittlerweile
Whisper macht das transcribing
Vom Stream
Miley macht die Fulltext Search
Also das ist aus unterschiedlichen
Quasi Hyper Agile
Microservices
Ach ist es?
Open Source
Hier Leute
Ich habe nichts gesagt
Das Archiv ist tatsächlich
Open Source
Also Svelte Kit Frontend
Python Backend
Go Backend
Und
Python Zeug für das transcribe
Sieht das aus?
Ist doch eigentlich
Ist doch eigentlich recht übersichtlich
Whisper Py
Geht doch
Ist doch eigentlich alles richtig gut lesbar
Easy
Very Easy
Hat jemand von euch die MW3 Beta gespielt?
Kommt die nicht erst für den PC?
Release
Ach ne
Die ist gestartet
Am Donnerstag
MW3 Beta in Gefahr
Cheat Anbieter verteilt kostenlose Hacks
Naja das war jetzt damit zu rechnen oder?
Ich mein
MW1 und 2 das ist alles so ähnlich
Das wird wahrscheinlich 1 zu 1 funktionieren
Am besten Leute
Eines der witzigsten Storys was Cheating Software
Angeht fand ich immer noch Battlefield 2042
Da wurde ja zum Release
Also mittlerweile ist es ja bei
Cheating Software auch so
Dass das oftmals als Abo Modell verkauft wird
Also du kaufst sie jetzt nicht
Über irgendwelche dubiosen Quellen
Wie hieß das Ding früher
XXX42
Oder sowas
Wie hieß das Ding noch zu Black Ops Zeiten
Ich hab's vergessen
Ich hab das nie benutzt keine Ahnung wie das heißt
X irgendwas mit X
X22 ja sowas genau
Ja ja X22
Also heute kaufst du dir das
Nicht einfach heute kaufst du ein
Abo für Cheating Software
Oder zumindest ist das da relativ beliebt
Kaufst ein Abo und
Battlefield 2042
Ist so kacke gelaunched
Und war so schnell so unbedeutend
Dass Anti-Cheating Anbieter
Also daran erkennst du wenn ein Game wirklich
Dead ist ja
Anti-Cheating Anbieter
Haben Battlefield 2042 Cheats
Aus dem Programm genommen und haben gesagt
Jeder der ein Abo abgeschlossen hat
Darf das kostenlos umstellen
Auf ein Abo für Cheating Software
Für ein anderes Spiel seiner Wahl
Sie entwickeln den Cheat nicht weiter
Das Game ist dead
Also daran erkennst du wenn was wirklich
Gefailt ist wenn 2 Monate nach Release
Die Anti-Cheating
Die Cheating Software
Eingestellt wird
Und du dein Abo kostenlos umstellen kannst
Daran siehst du das Game ist wirklich
Unbedeutend
BF5 wird wahrscheinlich noch weiter
Entwickelt
Ist die eigentlich auch auf dem PC
Ah ja hier zudem gibt es für
Wann startet
Ab
Die ganze Modern Warfare Reihe und hieß es nicht mal, dass Call of Duty nur noch alle zwei Jahre kommen soll.
Mittlerweile sind wir wieder bei jedes Jahr, aber gut, verkauft sich ja anscheinend auch.
Aber richtig Kohle machen die wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich mit Warzone.
Warzone struggelt ja auch ein bisschen jetzt, letzter Zeit habe ich mitbekommen.
Aber es wird immer noch massig Geld machen.
Du machst gerade dein was? Fachinformatiker, Anwend... Warum muss man das so krass abkürzen?
Fachinformatiker, Anwend... Mach gerade Netzwerktechnik.
Netzwerktechnik, Cisco und Co. Warum?
Ist doch gar nicht verkehrt.
Was ist daran so schlimm?
Ja, da hast du recht, da gebe ich dir recht.
Generell, es ist halt sehr head glitch, up aim heavy.
Zu kompliziert?
Ja, also...
Das ist Übungssache.
Und gerade Netzwerk Basics sollte man können, auch als Anwendungsentwickler.
Weil da musst du ja auch, wenn du was programmierst, das ein oder andere Mal drauf achten.
Das haben wir aber viel weniger gespielt.
Ja, ich vergesse immer, dass das der gleiche, dass das zu diesem ganzen Activision Blizzard Ding,
ja auch, ich habe vergessen, wie die Candy Crush Leute heißen, gehören.
King Games? Oder waren das andere?
Ich glaube, die gehören auch dabei.
Wobei es mittlerweile ja alles zu Microsoft gehört.
Seit gestern. Seit gestern ist es ja offiziell durch.
Activision Blizzard gehört zu Microsoft.
Ja, habe ich gesehen. Es gab sogar auch irgendwie Free Weekend oder sowas.
Ich habe mich letztens gewundert, warum auf einen Schlag 80.000 Leute auf Steam online waren.
Was ist da los?
Ja, Packet Tracer ist auch sehr praktisch zum Netzwerk Basics sich angucken.
Vor allem, weil man Step für Step alles durchklicken kann, wie was passiert.
Packet Tracer haben wir ja auch schon im Stream.
Guck mal, ich zeige dir mal das geile Archiv.
Packet Tracer.
Guck, hier sieht man es doch.
Da werden die Pakete getracert.
Und das Nice am Packet Tracer ist halt, dass man einzelne Steps, man sieht es ja hier,
man kann jetzt im Simulator auf Weiter klicken.
Und dann sieht man, Paket geht dahin, dahin, dahin und kann dann auch reinschauen, was da drin steht.
Das ist kostenlos übrigens, kann sich jeder runterladen.
Man braucht einen Cisco Academy Account, aber den kann man sich kostenlos erstellen.
Auch mit Fake E-Mail Adresse.
Also das ist sehr praktisch, das Ding.
Ja.
Ja, seit gestern ist das durch.
Ja, nice.
Also, ich finde Packet Tracer eine richtig gute Sache.
Also ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen, dass das zu Kernaufgaben von einem Anwendungsentwickler gehört,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll und zu einem gewissen Grad auch notwendig,
dass man Netzwerk Basics checkt.
Und mal so die grundlegenden Sachen am Switch zu konfigurieren, ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Könnt ihr euch noch an das Video erinnern, von diesem gestellten Ausfall,
wo der Ausbilder den Port runtergefahren hat und dann neben dem Azubi stand,
und die ganze Zeit irgendwie gesagt hat, was er tippen soll und eigentlich schon wissen müsste und so.
Nico hieß der Azubi.
Genau, habe ich mir gemerkt, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Alter, der Ausbilder geht mir auf den Keks, man.
Nico hätte es ohne Probleme alleine hingekriegt, ohne den Typ daneben.
Ah, ist Übungssache.
Spricht ja nichts dagegen, du kannst ja den Packet Tracer auch bei dir daheim mal draufhauen und ein bisschen rumklicken.
Da kommt man schon dahinter.
Aufgeregt habe ich mich ja schon ein paar Mal.
Was fällt dir denn schwer an den Cisco-Netzwerk-Sachen?
Also was ich schwierig finde, generell jetzt bei Cisco-Konfigurationen,
nicht so sehr Netzwerk-basis, Cisco-Konfigurationen,
man muss sich halt erstmal ein bisschen an die CLI gewöhnen von den Switchen.
Und ich habe die Hälfte auch schon vergessen.
Ich weiß nur noch, das erste, was man macht, ist N, EN und dann CONF T.
Mehr weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ja, und No Shutdown für den Port.
Und Show IP, Fragezeichen, wenn man nicht weiter weiß.
CLI ist tatsächlich ein bisschen kompliziert, weil man halt in diesen Cisco-Way sich reindenken muss.
Subnetze vergeben ist easy.
Subnetze vergeben, startest da einfach deine Ledungskiste.
Okay, das darfst du aber in der Arbeit wahrscheinlich nicht verwenden, aber...
Aber Subnetzing musst du zumindest während der Ausbildung ein bisschen checken,
weil das kommt auch in der Prüfung dran und das wollen die immer mal wissen.
Ich kann es auch nur noch mit sehr viel Hirn verdrehen.
Aber später macht man das einfach so.
Ups.
Später würde man...
What the...
Hallo.
Ich würde gerne hier rein tippen dürfen.
Ja, nice.
Später sagst du einfach IP-Kalk.
So.
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Und dann hast du deine Netzaufteilung, ja.
Natürlich kannst du das nicht in der Arbeit verwenden.
Du kriegst sogar Binary-Ansicht.
Aber wie gesagt, in der Arbeit kannst du es nicht verwenden.
Das heißt, du musst das irgendwie zumindest mal kurzfristig für die Arbeit
in deiner Abschlussprüfung während der Ausbildung checken.
Danach...
Danach kannst du es wieder vergessen.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es easy ist, weil ich hab das mal verstanden
und ich glaube, jetzt würde ich mir da bei komplizierten Sachen auch schwer tun.
Ja, die...
Die IHK ist nicht bekannt dafür, realitätsnah zu sein.
Ja, genau, das ist so eine typische...
Also Klasse B würde man ja heute nicht mal wirklich sagen.
Aber das ist so eine typische Frage.
Insgesamt sollen mindestens 2000 Haus sein.
Wie viele Bits muss der Haus...
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist so eine typische IHK-Frage.
Also ist das bei dir anders?
Darfst du den IP-Calculator verwenden in der Arbeit?
Oder in der Abschlussprüfung?
Was das sagt?
Das sagt easy as fuck, sagt das.
Easy as fuck.
Easy as fuck, sagt das.
Das kann auch sagen...
Get rekt.
Das ist ein koreanischer... eine koreanische Text-to-Speech-Engine,
die wir auf Aussprache ultra happy umgestellt haben.
Deswegen klingt die auch so glücklich, wenn sie easy as fuck sagt.
Easy as fuck.
Oder...
360.
Noscope.
Nice.
Oder, oder...
Subscriber.
Deswegen klingt die super happy.
Weil man konnte bei dieser Text-to-Speech-Engine...
konnte man irgendwie so Begeisterungsgrad einstellen.
Wir haben den voll hochgedreht.
Deswegen kann ich auch sagen...
Subscriber.
Internet während der Prüfung.
Okay, da würde ich mir Gedanken machen,
ob man nicht einfach einen Chat aufmacht und die Leute fragt...
Also...
Was ist das für eine Text-to-Speech-Engine?
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Wir können mal nachgucken.
Irgendwo hier ist der Source Code davon.
Das ist uralt.
Das ist noch .NET Framework 4.8 oder sowas.
Ich habe hier gar nichts mehr drauf.
Wo könnte das drin sein?
Models?
Nein.
Help?
FFmpeg?
Nee.
Services?
Text-to-Speech-Service.
Das klingt gut.
Ja, Notepad ist das Beste für C-Sharp-Code.
Das wissen wir alle.
Text-to-Speech-Service.
Wir verwenden...
Ah, API-Key leaked.
Oder was auch immer.
API-Key leaked.
Wir verwenden...
Hier.
api.voicetext.japan
Speaker Hikari.
Hier.
Emotion Happiness.
Die sind umgezogen.
Ja, aber die API-Funzen anscheinend immer noch.
Wobei, nee.
Ich habe mir das ja lokal zwischengespeichert.
Vielleicht.
Hier.
Happiness Emotion Level 4.
Mehr ging nicht.
Und deswegen klingt die so ultra glücklich, wenn sie sagt Subscriber.
So, lass uns mal ShitHub Trends angucken der letzten Woche.
Ob da irgendwas Spannendes drin ist.
Was trendet denn hier?
Was haben wir denn?
AI. Juckt mich nicht.
AI. AI. AI. AI.
Space Drive.
Das hat letztens irgendjemand empfohlen, dass ich mir das mal angucke.
Aber...
Cross-Platform File Explorer.
Ähm...
Written in Rust.
Ist das wieder so ein Tool, wo der einzige Scham ist, dass es written in Rust ist?
Oder was kann das Geiles?
Das ist ein File Explorer.
Pog.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Elektron, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ist es aber anscheinend nicht.
Scheint High-IQ-Shit zu sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Brauche ich wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
AI. AI.
Rust.
Oh, guck mal.
Hier kann man lernen, wie man Android mit Rust programmiert.
AI.
Äh, nee.
Sales.
Uah.
Ah.
Monka.
W, Alter.
W.
Monka.
Open-Source-IDE-Testing.
Das ist quasi Postman mit eigenem IDE-Style-Fenster.
Homepage.
Super.
AI.
Was ist so Schlimmes an Salesforce?
Das ist für mich nix.
Das ist genauso, was so schlimm an SAP ist.
Das ist so Ultra-Business-Enterprise-Nerv-Software.
The most advanced embedded vector search engine.
Okay, Leute.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das überhaupt sein soll.
Aber es ist in Java entwickelt.
Das bringt mir für meine meisten...
Tja.
Blazing...
Es ist entweder blazingly fast oder es funktioniert nicht.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Zeigt mal ein Bild.
Zeigt mal ein Bild davon.
Open-Source-IDE for exploring and testing RPs.
Lightweight alternative to Postman.
Okay, ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht, dass Postman eine Lightweight-Alternative ist.
Aber gut, dann gucken wir mal, was daran Lightweight ist.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Visual Studio-Plugin.
Es ist bestimmt Elektron, oder?
ChatGear, was meint ihr?
Elektron-Basis, oder nicht?
Ich tippe ganz stark auf Elektron-Basis.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin ja Team Curl.
Ich benutze eigentlich hauptsächlich Curl.
Und weder Postman noch dieses komische in JetBrains-IDEs für einfach Curl und gut ist.
Ja, mir ist auch klar, irgendwelche Kommunikationen geskriptet ablaufen lassen ist natürlich in Curl nicht so easy wie vielleicht in anderen Sachen.
Und aufzeichnen ist mit Curl auch nicht.
Ja, man kann nicht alles mit Curl machen, was man mit den anderen machen kann.
Aber in der Regel, irgendeine APN.curl und ein bisschen JSON hinschicken, das geht mit Curl wunderbar.
Ich werde mit dem ganzen Zeug nicht warm.
Ich habe seit langer Zeit Postman installiert und ab und zu benutze ich das auch mal.
Aber hauptsächlich 99% Curl.
Ja, klar, ich verstehe den Anwendungszweck schon.
Wenn du dir irgendwelche Sachen sharen willst, zum Beispiel irgendwelche Tests.
Du sagst, hey, wir haben hier 50 Sachen und nicht jeder muss sich was eigenes ausdenken.
Ja, ja, verstehe ich alles.
Aber bei mir reicht trotzdem zu 90% und zu 99% Curl.
Und eine Sache, die mich auch bei Postman nach einer Weile abgeschreckt hat, ist, dass die mich mittlerweile dort auch für irgendein API-Testing-Tool zu irgendeinem Account nötigen wollen.
So, das ist bestimmt auf Elektron-Base.
Lasst mal gucken hier.
Wo ist denn überhaupt der Source-Code?
Chatge.
Packages?
Ja.
Source.
Moment, wir gucken einfach in die Package, Jason.
Elektron.
Ja.
Hä?
Was sonst?
Wie kann man APIs testen, wenn es ein Offline-Tool ist?
Oder habe ich nicht alles?
Naja, dann nicht.
Wenn du aber eine eigene Software, wenn du was eigenes entwickelst bei dir, startest das auf dem Entwicklerrechner und willst dann irgendwelche Tests durchlaufen lassen oder irgendwas ausprobieren, dann kann das durchaus sinnvoll sein.
Ansonsten, wenn das Netzwerk Zugriff braucht und du bist Offline, dann kannst du es natürlich nicht ausprobieren.
Aber was, also diese Tools haben ja viele Möglichkeiten.
Was ich ganz gut finde, du kannst doch beispielsweise bestimmte Sachen mitschneiden und dann replayen lassen und sowas.
So, was hat man sonst noch?
AI.
Ähm.
AI?
Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ne, ist es nicht.
NeoVim.
Steht übrigens auch noch auf dem Plan, dass wir uns das näher angucken.
Aber nicht LazyVim, sondern NeoVim from Scratch.
AI.
IT-Tools.
Was soll das sein?
Hä?
So heißt es nicht.
JavaScript.
BERT.
Witz 2 Backbone with BERT.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Im Zweifelsfall würde ich mal auf AI tippen.
Tabby.
Okay, ja.
Wenn man unbedingt unter Windows unterwegs sein muss.
Laura.
Haben wir im Stream auch schon mal ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt.
Local IP Testing.
Chat-GPT for free.
AI-Zeug.
Ja, nicht so spannend diese Woche, was es gibt.
Today.
Was ist denn hier?
Bleeding Edge auf GitHub.
Postgres-Driver für Go.
We need this Autoscaler.
Move it for ROS 2.
Ist das Runescape Online oder was ist das?
Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Ne.
Was?
Was ist das?
Robot Software Component?
Okay, es hat nichts mit Runescape zu tun.
Roboter-Framework.
High-Performance-Chatbot-Framework.
Coggers VLM.
Deno.
Ja.
Also diese Woche war nicht so viel Trendendes dabei.
Was mich interessiert hat.
So.
Was haben wir denn hier auf YouTube heute?
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Ne, das wollte ich mir doch angucken.
Lul.
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration vom Arbeitsamt.
Was erzählen sie uns denn?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Was erzählen sie uns denn da drüber?
Das wird was.
Dice of Grinch.
Vielleicht taugt es auch.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Initial, ob das Sound richtig stimmt.
Oh, jetzt wird es ein bisschen laut hier.
Aber ich glaube die Lautstärke ist gut.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Drei Minuten vom Arbeitsamt.
Was gibt es hier?
Also, eins muss ich mal sagen.
Ich habe mir ja teilweise diese Videos ganz gerne angeguckt.
Und die sind auch per se nicht schlecht oder so.
Aber ich habe fast den Eindruck.
Jedes Video, was ich empfohlen kriege von Hardware Deals ist mittlerweile nur noch.
Ich habe mir eine Grafikkarte von AliExpress gekauft.
Ich habe mir einen China-CPU gekauft.
Ich habe mir einen China-Komplett-PC gekauft.
Ich habe mir China aus China importieren lassen.
Weiß nicht, Alter.
Man gibt sich was anderes.
Ich verstehe es aber auch.
Es läuft halt gut.
Da kann man ja gar nichts dagegen sagen.
Aber es ist echt immer der gleiche Kram.
Zumindest was mir empfohlen wird.
Vielleicht wird mir auch nur das Zeug empfohlen.
Weil es das Einzige ist, was ich mal angeklickt habe in letzter Zeit.
Okay, also.
Was erzählt ihr?
Was machen die da eigentlich gerade?
Okay, er trägt Monitore rum.
Lass uns schauen.
So.
Und jetzt stecken sie ein ganz, ganz kurzes Kabel in ein Patch-Panel rein.
Und dann.
Haben sie es reingesteckt.
Datschi-Buzz.
Die Ausbildung Fachinformatikerin für Systemintegration ist abwechslungsreich.
Hier arbeitest du mit Tat und Software.
Außerdem bist du Problemlöser.
Sollten Kollegen Probleme am Computer haben, stehst du mit Rat und Tat zur Seite.
Nee.
Das ist das Letzte, was ich mache bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Endkunden-Support, Alter.
Nee, Endkunden ist das falsche Wort.
Ja, wie nennt man das?
User-Support.
Alter.
Keine zwei Tage würde ich das machen, ey.
Sollten Kollegen Probleme am Computer haben, stehst du mit Rat und Tat zur Seite.
Also meine Lieblingsfächer und besten Fächer in der Schule waren Mathe und Informatik.
Was, denke ich, mal logisch ist.
Wir hatten auch Informatik.
Das hieß IT-Systeme bei uns in der Schule.
Und wisst ihr, ich glaube, ich habe es schon 500 Mal erzählt.
Wisst ihr, was wir gemacht haben in dem Fach IT-Systeme bei mir in der Schule?
Also bei mir in der Schule heißt das war 2000 rum so.
1999, 98 und so.
98 oder so war das, glaube ich, das letzte Jahr, oder?
Ich meine, ich bin 1984 geboren.
Das heißt, man kommt eben mit 7 oder so in der Schule.
98 oder so was.
Mit 14, 15, 15 vielleicht 99, so was.
Ja, wir haben Office gemacht.
Wir haben fast nur Office gemacht.
Wir hatten einen Lehrer, der hatte keine Ahnung eigentlich von Technik.
Das Einzige, was der konnte, ist in Word irgendwelche Briefe schreiben oder Excel.
Wir haben sogar Access benutzt.
Access, Alter.
Die größte Shit-Software aller Zeiten.
Und man hat bei dem immer eine Eins bekommen, bei dem Lehrer.
Wenn man die Dokumente lila gefärbt hat.
Das ist kein Witz.
Dann hat er immer.
Ich weiß, es ist cringe und ich habe es auch schon 5 mal erzählt.
Dann hat er immer gesagt, Leila, Leila, Leila und hat eine Eins gekriegt.
Du musstest einfach nur das Dokument lila färben.
Es war schon weird champig alles.
Also 10 Finger schreiben haben wir da nicht gelernt, weil das konnte der Kerl selbst nicht.
Ich kann es bis heute nicht.
Leute, Frage, wer von euch kann blind 10 Finger schreiben?
Bloated?
Nope.
2 Leute? 3 Leute?
4 Leute?
5?
Okay, also wir haben ein paar, die das können.
Okay, das war aber das andere Extrem.
Wer von euch, aber das dürften wahrscheinlich die wenigsten sein.
Wer von euch macht noch 2 Finger Adler-Suchsystem?
Wahrscheinlich keiner, aber wirklich.
Also Leute, die sich das jagen, eher nicht.
Also 2 Finger, es ist ja so.
Ich glaube, die meisten hier werden das ähnlich machen wie ich.
So ein eigenes 5 bis 8 Finger Halb-Blind-Tipp-System.
Ich habe kein System, was man irgendwie System nennen könnte.
Aber ich meine Hallo, Keckel, Chat.
Das habe ich jetzt blind geschrieben zum Beispiel.
Das ist so eine Mischung aus Finger, wo ich denke, dass es irgendwie hin muss.
Und auch nicht immer die gleichen Finger.
Als System kann man das nicht nennen.
Ja, so mache ich das auch.
Und ich gucke auch ganz gerne mal immer wieder zwischendurch Keck W auf die Tastatur.
Ich habe da so ein eigenes Ding.
Letztendlich so die Standard-Linux-Dinger.
Also ich kann die meisten Sachen eigentlich blind treffen.
Aber ich gucke trotzdem beim Überlegen immer mal wieder auf die Tastatur.
Ich finde so eine super krasse, auch wenn das teilweise in Videos angepriesen wird.
Es gibt ja immer so Videos, How-to-Productivity-Tipps und sowas.
Ich muss sagen, so die super krasse Produktivitätssteigerung zu einem richtig echten Zehn-Finger-Blind-Tippen glaube ich gar nicht mal.
Weil Zehn-Finger-Blind-Tippen reicht ja gar nicht.
Man müsste ja Zehn-Finger-Blind inklusive allen Sonderzeichen tippen können.
Dann wird es halt schon ein bisschen schwieriger.
Ja, das denke ich mir auch.
Ich kann aus allen Haltungen und Lagen hier irgendwelche Sachen ein...
Ups. Ja, nice Chat. LSLA hinten dran. Besse.
Pop-out gleich LS-LA.
Also ich sehe, ihr macht es wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Ich finde auch nicht, dass es wirklich notwendig ist.
Weil die meiste Zeit ist man eh am Überlegen und am Nachdenken halt.
So, also schauen wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Schule waren Mathe und Informatik.
Das denke ich mal logisch ist.
Ich kenne genug, die nicht gut in Mathe waren.
Aber auch Englisch ist sehr wichtig, weil sehr viele Anleitungen...
Das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Ich muss sagen, ich war nie sonderlich gut in Englisch in der Schule.
Das lag aber auch daran, weil mir die Lehrer auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Mittlerweile...
We are all sitting in one boat.
Mittlerweile geht es eigentlich.
Mir fehlt schlicht und ergreifend die Praxis, was das Speaken angeht.
Aber...
Ich meine, ich gucke die meisten Filme und Sachen auch nur noch in Englisch.
Und lese quasi zu 90% englische Webseiten.
Also da kommt man durch ohne Probleme mittlerweile.
Das Reden ist Übungssache.
Ich muss auf der Arbeit mittlerweile öfters Englisch reden,
weil wir haben einen Spanier bei uns im Team.
Im erweiterten Team haben wir einen Spanier.
Und nachdem ich kein Spanisch kann und er kein Deutsch kann,
reden wir Englisch und das geht eigentlich ganz gut.
Solange sich das um technische Themen dreht, überhaupt kein Ding.
Und ein bisschen Smalltalk drumherum geht auch.
Ich meine, ich könnte jetzt sicherlich nicht irgendwelche...
mittelalterlichen, philosophischen englischen Texte lesen oder so.
Da wäre ich aufgeschmissen.
Aber ganz im Ernst, selbst die meisten Native Speaker in Deutsch
also Muttersprachler könnte man sagen,
haben Probleme, ältere deutsche Texte ordentlich zu lesen.
Also das würde ich mir jetzt da keine Gedanken drum machen.
Und klar, aus irgendwelchen anderen Fachgebieten
habe ich auf Englisch auch keine Ahnung.
Aber Alltagssachen und so würde ich da denke ich...
also ich müsste dort nicht verhungern
und ich könnte da mich auch durchmogeln.
Das wird schon funktionieren.
Mir fehlt halt so die Sprechübung.
Weil außer mit unserem Spanier
und das übliche Denglish, was ich hier fabriziere,
habe ich halt nichts.
Ja, ich kann mich auf der Gamescom erinnern,
auf der Gamescom war es auch immer so,
so der erste halbe Tag bis Tag war immer ein bisschen gestottert,
aber danach ging es.
Englisch-Stream, oh ja, ganz bestimmt.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet, dass wir Englisch-Stream machen.
Okay, jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört.
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich muss jetzt mal das Video laufen lassen.
Kecklst und Lul, wie ist du eigentlich auch real life, ja?
Ich habe doch gestern mal mit der GoPro ein Video aufgenommen,
wie ich Fahrrad gefahren bin
und dazwischendrin habe ich mal für euch ein bisschen gelabert im Hintergrund.
Also wir haben uns gestern nur zwei, drei Minuten Ausschnitt daraus ausgeguckt
und wir gucken uns das auch nicht komplett an,
das war nur so ein Aufnahmetest.
Und ich habe im Hintergrund ein bisschen gelabert
und ich habe allen Ernstes, während ich Fahrrad fahren war,
mehrfach gesagt, Monkastier, Lulw und Keckl bestimmt auch.
Also ich rede auch normal so anscheinend.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal, ihr lauft an irgendeinem vorbei
und er kommt euch mit dem Fahrrad entgegen
und ihr hört von dem beim Fahrradfahren Monkastier.
Gut, die meisten Leute werden es nicht checken,
die denken halt, der telefoniert gerade und labert dummes Zeug vor sich hin.
Würde so Keck wehen, ja, ich auch.
Also wenn ihr mal irgendeinen auf dem blauen Fahrrad rumfahren seht,
in der Nähe von Frankfurt, der Monkastier sagt beim Fahren,
dann bin ich das wahrscheinlich.
Okay, also wir gucken jetzt echt das Video fertig.
Ist das ein Raspberry Pi?
Ne, ist es nicht.
Das ist ein Dell Optiplex Microservice Manual, Handbuch.
Sehr wichtig, weil sehr viele Anleitungen
oder Sachen, die man recherchieren muss im Internet,
einfach auf Englisch sind und nicht übersetzt sind.
Und es ist auch gut so, dass das nicht übersetzt ist.
Ich meine ernsthaft, hier, machen wir mal, keine Ahnung.
So, alter, die Microsoft-Seite ist so kacke,
ich finde den Knopf noch nicht mal.
Das hat doch so einen Translation-Knopf immer oben gehabt.
Wo ist denn der hin? Ist der weg?
Microsoft-Seite, die macht mich so fertig.
Ne, es gibt auf der Microsoft-Seite,
gibt es doch immer hier so Knöpfe neben,
wo man das translaten kann.
Warum ist denn das jetzt weg?
Ich meine, das geht auch, aber...
Ja, maschinell übersetzt, ja.
Ich meine, guckt euch das an,
wenn man sich das hier teilweise durchliest.
Man will das einfach nicht auf Deutsch lesen, ja.
Es ist gut, dass es nicht übersetzt wird.
Man will das gar nicht auf Deutsch lesen oftmals.
Zumal man halt auch nichts findet,
wenn man nach Fehlern sucht auf Deutsch.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ja, das ist immer etwas verkehrt.
Ja, das könnte man sagen,
das trifft auf nahezu jeden halbwegs
Kundenorientierung und Ausdrucksvermögen.
Also Kunden, je nachdem, was man als Kunde definiert,
gehen mir eher auf den Keks,
anstatt dass ich da sonderlich orientiert bin.
Also wenn man jetzt irgendwelche Endanwender meint,
die mich fragen würden,
wie stelle ich in Excel das und das ein,
dann wäre ich nicht sonderlich...
Aber das wäre auch nicht der richtige Job für mich.
Leute, Excel-Kenner unter euch,
wie kann ich in Excel...
Ich drehe nämlich immer durch,
wenn ich Office-Shit verwenden muss, ja.
Wie kann ich in Excel
alle Wörter,
also wenn ich jetzt nach dem Wort kekw suche
in der Excel-Tabelle,
wie kann ich alle Vorkommnisse
des Wortes kekw highlighten lassen?
Beziehungsweise wenigstens zu der Zelle springen,
wo kekw drinne steht.
Aktuell, wenn ich in Excel nach kekw suche,
dann highlightet er mir jede Zeile,
wo irgendwo in der Zeile kekw vorkommt.
Das ist richtig dämlich.
Da kannst du überhaupt nichts suchen drin.
Ja, der durchsucht die ganze Mappe,
aber der durchsucht jede Zeile,
wo kekw drinne kommt.
Ich will die Zelle haben.
Kann man nicht einstellen,
zumindest nicht da,
in dem normalen Search-Dialog.
Jetzt lassen wir das Video durchlaufen.
In der Praxis stellen Betriebe daher oft
Auszubildende mit Hochschulreife
oder mittlerer Reife ein.
Ja.
Die Ausbildung selbst dauert dann
drei Jahre im dualen System,
du wechselst also zu spät.
Es ist ein virtuelles Teams-Klassen-Treffen.
Ausbildungsbetrieb und Berufsschule.
Also quasi, ja, keine Ahnung.
Wenn du zu Hause derjenige bist,
der den Drucker installieren
oder das Handy installieren muss,
dann bist du für die Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
mit Systemintegration genau richtig.
Drucker.
Das lernst du.
Den Aufbau und die Installation von Hard- und Software,
das Programmieren und Coden,
Kundenumgang im Anwendersupport.
Hör mal auf.
Alter, ich würde im Leben
nicht diese Ausbildung anfangen
mit dieser Beschreibung, Mann.
Kundensupport,
Kundenumgang im Anwendersupport,
Drucker installieren.
Wenn das,
hätten die mir das angekündigt damals,
hätte ich im Leben nicht
diese Ausbildung gemacht.
Glücklicherweise habe ich mit
Kundensupport und Druckern auch nichts zu tun.
Also in dem Beruf hat man regelmäßig
Kontakt zu anderen Menschen,
da man wirklich tatsächlich
ein IT-Problem hat.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das schwebt vielleicht der IHK
oder dem Arbeitsamt vor.
Das ist ganz entscheidend davon abhängig,
wo, in welcher Firma
und in welchem Team, in welcher Position,
wo man seine Ausbildung macht.
Ich würde sogar sagen,
die wenigsten Physis
machen reinen Druckerwechsel-Support.
Ich meine, vielleicht bin ich da
auch ein bisschen vorbelastet.
Ich habe ja die Ausbildung damals
bei einem Internet-Provider gemacht
und ich hatte nie großartig
Endkundenkontakt, aber Endkundenkontakt,
das ist das Nervigste und Schlimmste,
was ich mir täglich vorstellen könnte.
Den Job würde ich nicht lange machen.
Ich habe ja eine ganze Weile
in der Nähe von unserem Support gehockt,
in einer alten Firma
und das war kein reiner,
das war kein Endkundensupport.
Also da hat nicht irgendjemand angerufen
und hat gesagt, hier beim Login
kommt ein Fehler oder sowas.
Da riefen interne Leute halt an
bei Problemen
mit irgendwelchen Services,
wo dann nachgeguckt wurde,
ah, guck mal hier,
Service ist auch gerade
Monitoring down oder was auch immer
und das, was ich da schon mitbekommen habe,
ging mir schon immer auf den Sack
und das war kein richtiger
Endkundensupport,
das war nochmal eine Nummer besser
und das war schon übelst nervig.
Also mein einziger,
mein einziger längerer Kontakt
kann man nicht sagen,
also Kontakt mit Endkunden war mal,
unser System geht nicht
und die E-Mail war falsch,
die war eindeutig falsch bei uns
und ich habe mich dazu
erbarmt,
auf diese E-Mail zu antworten
und habe ihr geschrieben,
sie ist bei uns falsch,
aber wenn sie mir sagt,
um welches System es geht,
dann kann ich die Anfrage
vielleicht weiterleiten an jemanden,
der sich damit auskennt
und ihre Antwort war nur noch,
ich meine das System,
das war nur ein Ausrufezeichen
und dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Da habe ich einfach gedacht,
dann viel Spaß.
Eine ultra bescheuerte Antwort, oder?
Was weiß ich?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das ist.
Deswegen ist es wichtig,
dass man da auch ein bisschen
empathisch und geduldig an das Thema angeht.
Oh ja, da bin ich genau der Richtige für.
Laptop geht aus,
neue Maus und Headsets,
Schutzglas, Handy defekt,
Tabulator bleibt stehen,
ey, das würde ich keine 2 Tage aushalten.
Das wäre echt der blanke Horror.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
anscheinend haben die nicht allzu viel zu tun,
wenn innerhalb von ein paar Tagen,
das ist das Einzige,
da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Dark Zone, das passt einfach,
die Leute sind teilweise richtig planlos.
Ich meine, nichts gegen Leute,
denen das Spaß macht.
Es gibt bestimmt Leute,
die finden da irgendwie ihre Erfüllung drin,
IT-Support zu machen.
Es mag auch seine schönen Seiten haben,
wenn du Leute hast,
die sich dann freuen,
wenn es funktioniert und alles.
Aber ich würde es keine 2 Tage aushalten.
Ja, Wurzeln der Problembeschreibung
sind auch mal oft so ein Ding.
Manchmal liegt es daran,
dass die Leute es selbst zu gut kennen
und die Hälfte skippen
oder selbst nicht wissen, was Sache ist.
Man hat einfach so viele verschiedene Sachen,
die auf einen zukommen,
vor allem wenn man dann
in ganz verschiedene Fälle,
weil jeder andere Mitarbeiter oder Kunde,
mit dem man da zu tun hat,
hat sein ganz eigenes Problem,
an das man sich dann ransetzt
und das versucht zu lösen.
Als Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration
findest du in fast allen
Wirtschaftsbereichen Arbeit.
Aber ein bisschen schrauben
würde ich schon ab und zu gerne machen.
Mache ich halt gar nicht mehr.
Ich meine, wann war ich das letzte Mal
im Rechenzentrum?
Ewig her.
Bestimmt ein Jahr, locker.
Locker ein Jahr her.
Kann mich jetzt gar nicht dran erinnern.
So ändern sich die Zeiten.
Von täglich durch mehrere
Serverräume laufen zu
irgendwann vor einem Jahr vielleicht.
Jedes Unternehmen oder Behörden,
Computer oder Programme.
Also in der Ausbildung lernt man,
die komplette Netzwerkinfrastruktur
aufzubauen.
Alle Hardwarekomponenten lernt man kennen.
Alle.
Nicht einfach Hardware,
aber alle Hardwarekomponenten.
Sie können Software verteilen
auf alle Clients,
auf alle Rechner.
Solange es Windows ist wahrscheinlich.
Einer Meister- oder Technikerprüfung
zum Beispiel im Bereich...
Niemand juckt das doch, Alter.
Juckt irgendjemand wirklich
die weiterführenden Physi aus?
Also es gibt ja,
wenn du Physi gelernt hast,
kannst du bei der IHK ja noch,
da gibt es ja noch so Weiterführungsdinger.
Gibt es jemand, den das juckt?
...technische Informatik
oder einem Studium an einer Fachhochschule,
zum Beispiel Informationstechnik.
Vielleicht schon,
ich habe noch nicht einen gesehen bis jetzt zumindest.
...die Schnittstelle zwischen Technik und Anwender.
Wenn du gerne anderen bei Problemen hilfst,
Freude an Technik und Tüfteln hast,
dann bist du hier richtig.
Ja, das stimmt.
Freude an Technik und Bastel
ist natürlich sinnvoll.
...Ist ein gefragter Beruf mit Perspektive.
Ja, das stimmt auch.
Die Vorstellung von dem Beruf
hätte mich jetzt halt komplett abgeschreckt,
ihn zu machen,
weil wenn eines der Kernsachen
Endkundensupport oder generell Support ist,
da wäre es bei mir halt schon vorbei gewesen.
Da muss man sich so viel
mit anderen Menschen auseinandersetzen,
da kriegst du ja Zustände.
Also mit nicht technikinteressierten
anderen Menschen,
da triffst du ja am Rad.
Was verdient ein Tennistrainer?
Wahrscheinlich ganz gut,
solange er Leute hat.
Also pro Stunde gut,
aber er wird nicht den ganzen Tag trainern.
Was haben wir da?
MetaQuest 3 im Test.
Äh, MetaQuest?
Ist das der Nachfolger von Oculus?
Weil Facebook hat,
also Meta hat ja das gekauft damals.
Ich blicke bei den Produktbezeichnungen
da nicht mehr durch.
Zumindest hat die erste Oculus Rift
ja diesen Riesen
vor so 5, 6 Jahren
diesen riesen neuen VR-Hype ausgelöst.
Das ist schon länger her,
wahrscheinlich 7, 8 Jahre.
Wo dann alle gesagt haben,
ja jetzt endlich VR, jetzt Durchbruch.
Aber nein, war es halt auch nicht.
Update sich der Chromium bei dir immer selbst?
Ja, beim Start
zeigt er einen Update-Dialog an,
ob ich upgraden will oder nicht.
Nee, über Winged nicht.
Ja, ich glaube das ist schon wieder
so lange her mit den VR-Brillen.
Man kann sich das ganz einfach überlegen.
War es vor Corona?
Ja.
Das heißt es ist schon mal 3, 4 Jahre her.
War es aktuell auf einer der Gamescoms,
wo ich zuletzt gewesen bin?
Ja, das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her.
Also insofern
muss das 6, 7 Jahre her sein,
wo der VR-Hype war.
Genau, und der Hype ist schon wieder vorbei.
Das heißt es muss eine Weile her gewesen sein.
Welche Windows-Packager,
wenn überhaupt tatsächlich Windows-Packager
gibt es in Winged,
aber das meiste wird installiert
und dann halt mit dem jeweiligen Updater,
die fast jede Software mitbringt, geupdatet.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich glaube ich muss VLC updaten.
Nein, muss ich nicht.
Ich habe gestern schon geupdatet.
Guck mal hier,
so sieht unser Konferenzraum aus,
wenn ich durch die neue Meta-Quest 3 durchgucke.
Das meiste ist echt,
aber das Loch da in der Decke,
das ist natürlich Computer.
Das hätte ich jetzt gedacht,
wenn ich das 3 durchgucke.
Das meiste ist echt,
aber das Loch da in der Decke,
das ist natürlich Computer-Grafik.
Ja gut, und auch die Monster hier.
Wenn ich das will,
kann ich aber auch nahtlos
zwischen meiner echten Umgebung
und einer komplett künstlichen VR-Welt umschalten.
Das sieht ziemlich cool aus.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
ist das nicht genau wie bei der Apple Vision Pro?
Ja, da habt ihr recht,
nur dass die Quest 3 statt 3.200 Euro
halt nur 550 Euro kostet.
Das jetzt ist eher was für Bastler und Entwickler.
Die Meta-Quest 3 ausführlich getestet
und zeigen euch,
wo die Unterschiede zur Apple-Brille liegen.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie das Ding,
was Sam Fisher früher aufhatte.
Aber natürlich auch Meta-Quest 3
im Vergleich zu günstigeren Headsets
wie der Quest 2 oder der Sony PSVR 2 abschneidet.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerin,
liebe Internet-Surfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von HP.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr sitzt an eurem Schreibtisch
und arbeitet an einem super wichtigen...
Okay, das war ein Sponsor, den sieht man nicht oft.
...an eurem Schreibtisch,
sondern im Hotel zum Beispiel.
Und plötzlich schwarzer Bildschirm, nichts geht mehr.
Panikanfall? Nein.
Denn wenn euer Laptop das HP Care Pack hat,
dann kriegt ihr drei Jahre Vorortservice
und telefonischen Support.
Statt jetzt lange zu googeln,
wo das Problem liegen könnte,
die aktuelle 3D-Brille oder die aktuelle VR, AR,
was auch immer Brille,
ist eindeutig für Entwickler und Bastler.
Da ist noch nichts für Endkunde gedacht.
Das kommt erst noch,
falls da was Gescheites bei rauskommt.
...dedizierten Support-Hotline an...
Was hältst du von HP-Druckern?
Ich würde nicht so unbedingt nach dem Hersteller gehen.
Ich halte prinzipiell von allen Druckern nichts,
die noch Tintenstrahldrucker sind.
Oder Tintenstrahldrucker,
egal welcher Hersteller.
Tintenstrahldrucker sind einfach
Shit ever.
Laserdrucker sind vollkommen okay.
Egal von welchem Hersteller.
Am besten ist natürlich,
wenn man ein Farblaser-Multifunktions-Ding hat,
dann hat man ausgesorgt für die nächsten Jahrzehnte.
HP...
Generell, seriously,
alle Tinten-Drucker her,
das ist alles Schrott.
Alles übertrieben Schrott.
Man braucht eine monatliche Subscription,
warum man trocken drucken darf.
Ja, dann würde ich es halt einfach nicht kaufen.
Also ich habe mir vor einer Weile
einen Brother Farblaser-Multifunktions-Ding gekauft.
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Die Dinger haben ja auch übelst bescheuerte Namen immer.
Und seitdem ich den habe, keine Probleme.
Ich drucke selten,
aber wenn ich drucken muss,
dann halt auch meistens mal irgendwie 20 Seiten oder so.
Und das war beim Tintenstrahldrucker
immer absoluter, ultra-mega-Abfuck.
Weil wenn du nur ein paar Mal im Jahr druckst,
musst du danach erstmal Düsenreinigung machen,
dann funktioniert es wieder nicht richtig.
Richtig scheiße.
Und jetzt Laserdrucker vom Tablet Air,
nee nicht Airplay, wie heißt das?
Airprint war das.
Dings, drucken, zack.
Es war anscheinend ausgedruckt, fertig.
Du druckst da wahrscheinlich auch,
wenn das Tinten, wenn das Tinte ist,
dann druckst du wahrscheinlich auch öfters
als 1-2 Mal im Jahr.
Also ich kaufe doch kein Abo,
um mit meinem gekauften Drucker zu drucken.
Also ich spinne, ja.
Brotherding ist wirklich ganz nice.
Leider haben die Dinger wieder
komplett wirre Produktbezeichnung.
Nämlich, obviously heißt das Ding,
wenn ich es gekauft habe, Moment.
Es heißt, ja wenn jetzt da der Produktname
noch irgendwie dabei stehen würde, hier.
MFC, so heißen die Brotherdinger ja alle,
L3750CDW.
Alles klar, Chat, ich finde es ist
komplett obviously, also obvious,
was dieser Produktname meint.
MFC L3750CDW, ganz klar.
Ich glaube das Einzige, was ich erkenne ist,
W ist wireless, color, ah duplex, ok.
Wenn man es weiß ergibt es sogar Sinn,
aber griffig ist was anderes.
Laser, Laser L3750, warum auch immer.
Ein OCR Scan, keine Ahnung ob das OCR Scan hat.
Juckt mich auch nicht, ob das OCR Scan hat.
Wenn ich OCR brauche, dann scanne ich es
und mache OCR mit irgendeiner eigenen Software dafür.
Ja, das Ding hier.
Das ist zwar ein bisschen größer
und vielleicht übelst overkill für jemanden,
der nicht oft druckt, aber es funktioniert einfach.
Und da wisst ihr was das Beste ist,
was man in Deutschland ja immer noch ab und zu braucht,
es hat ein Fax.
Man kann damit Faxe schicken, wenn man will.
Guck, er druckt, er kopiert, er scannt und er faxt.
Aber er kann nicht faxen bei mir,
weil ich kein Telefonkabel eingesteckt habe.
Ich habe auch nicht vor ein Telefonkabel einzustecken,
aber ich könnte ein Telefonkabel einstecken, wenn ich will.
Da werden Faxen gemacht, ja.
Ich schicke keine Faxe mehr
und wenn, würde ich gar keinen Fax damit schicken,
sondern über irgendeinen Webservice.
Aber immerhin, man könnte Faxe schicken
und dementsprechend ist ja auch Deutschlandbehörden-ready.
Tschetke, mich hat gar keiner ans Trinken erinnert in letzter Zeit,
das ist schlecht, jetzt habe ich ganz rauen Hals,
ich muss noch was trinken.
Fax denn wirklich noch jemand, ja?
In Deutschland ist Fax immer noch recht beliebt?
Guck mal bei irgendwelchen Behörden.
War es nicht sogar so, dass am Anfang von Corona
die Zahlen noch per Post übermittelt wurden oder per Fax
und wenn das Fax samstags eingetroffen ist,
war keiner da, der es lesen konnte und so komische Dinge?
Also mich würde das nicht wundern,
wenn es heute immer noch so wäre, dass viele Faxen machen.
Indirekt gibt es das ja schon.
Du kannst heute Faxe schicken über deinen Telefonanschluss,
der eigentlich nur noch ein VoIP-Anschluss ist.
Also Fax ist in Deutschland immer noch angesagt.
8 bis 17 Uhr für euch da, auch aus dem Ausland
und die versuchen dann zuerst remote das Problem mit euch zu lösen.
Sollte das nicht klappen, kommt ein von HP
autorisierter Techniker oder Technikerin zu euch,
die das Gerät entweder mit einem Ersatzteil reparieren
oder gleich ganz austauschen.
Laut HP können in der Regel 80% der Probleme
spätestens am nächsten Werktag gelöst werden.
Das heißt, ihr müsst das Gerät nicht irgendwo hinstellen,
Wisst ihr was geil wäre?
Wenn die ein Notebook ausliefern würden,
das durch Laufen kaputt geht.
Das wäre auch Bock.
Erst mal warten, sondern es kommt garantiert jemand zu euch
mit der Lösung. Klingt gut, oder?
Ja, das HP Care Pack ist Teil des HP Hardware Services
im Security Bundle und direkt beim Kauf
von ausgewählten HP Rechnern dabei.
Ganz ohne Aufpreis.
Mehr dazu in der Videobeschreibung.
Ob das so ein Verkaufsargument ist?
Ich bin ja schon seit Jahren so ein VR-Typ.
Ich gar nicht.
Wie kommt es darauf, dass ich mich für VR interessiere?
Deshalb ist die Quest 3 für mich eine echt große Sache,
weil der Vorgänger Quest 2 mit ziemlichem Abstand
das meistverkaufte VR-Headset aller Zeiten ist.
Man geht von fast 20 Millionen verkauften Stück aus.
Anders als PC-Headsets wie der Valve Index
oder der PlayStation VR 2,
muss man keinen PC oder Konsole an Quest-Headsets anschließen.
Die laufen komplett autark.
Da ist ein Android-System integriert.
Man kann also einfach in irgendeinen Raum gehen
und kurz mal in die virtuelle Realität springen,
ohne über irgendwelche Kabel nachzudenken.
Ihr könnt die Quest 3 aber auch...
Wireless ist natürlich nice.
Also das erste Mal, wo ich VR auf der Gamescom ausprobiert habe,
war das alles noch mit Kabel.
Und da ist permanent einer hinter dir hergelaufen
und hat die Kabel so getragen, dass du nicht drüberfällst.
...dekoppeln.
Das geht einfach mit einem USB-Kabel oder sogar über WLAN.
Dann könnt ihr grafisch aufwendigere PC-Spiele spielen.
Ziemlich praktisch.
Allerdings ist die Nachfrage nach Quest-Headsets
stark eingebrochen.
Offenbar hat Meta doll von der Pandemie profitiert.
Aber nun gibt es ja neue Hardware.
Meta hatte uns vor Verkaufsstart
ein Quest-3-Testgerät zur Verfügung gestellt.
Wir haben aber auch selbst noch eins gekauft.
Seit dem 10. Oktober werden die Headsets ausgeliefert.
Die 128-GB-Version kostet 550 Euro,
die 512er-Version 700 Euro.
Das ist ein steiler Preissprung.
Die Quest 2 gibt es ja mit 128...
Okay, ja, das ist ein steiler Preissprung.
Man muss aber sagen,
das ist immer noch ein verhältnismäßiger Preis.
Vergleicht mal das kleine iPhone 14, 15
mit dem 512G-iPhone 14, 15.
Da ist kein Preissprung von 100, 150 Euro.
Das sind eher...
Keine Ahnung, wie viel?
300, 400 Euro?
Wenn du überlegst,
heute kriegst du eine halbwegs schnelle Micro-SD-Karte
in der Größe schon für 40 Euro.
Okay, da wird vielleicht noch ein bisschen
von der Qualität gesprochen,
aber ich glaube,
das ist ein guter Preis.
Also, die Speicherpreise sind hyper-pipiger bei Smartphones.
700 Euro.
Das ist ein steiler Preissprung.
Die Quest 2 gibt es ja mit 128-GB
für 350 Euro schon.
Was kriegt man also für die 200 Euro Aufpreis?
Ich habe euch mal drei Verbesserungen
hier zusammengestellt.
Verbesserung Nummer 1.
Path-Through-Mixed-Reality.
Der wohl auffälligste Unterschied
ist die sogenannte Path-Through-Funktion.
Man sieht es halt einfach nicht.
Man sieht es einfach nicht.
Die eigentliche Umgebung per Kamera einfängt
und in Quasi-Echtzeit im Headset anzeigt.
Das Bild kann dann mit künstlichen Bildelementen
angereichert werden,
also Augmented Reality
oder wie man heute meist sagt,
Mixed Reality.
Ja, ich suche den Sinn auch noch ein bisschen.
Ich meine, für Games, ja, nice,
aber es gibt nicht so viele VR-Games.
Also, Half-Life Alyx ist das einzige Game,
wo ich sagen würde,
ey, da hätte ich richtig Bock drauf.
Vielleicht noch Resident Evil,
das voll das VR-Reality ist.
Vielleicht noch Resident Evil.
Ansonsten gibt es da nicht so viel.
Und für diese ganze Mixed-Reality-Geschichte
habe ich persönlich
gar keinen Anwendungszweck.
Okay, seriously,
wir wissen alle,
und ihr wisst es auch,
wofür VR am meisten verwendet wird.
Es ist nicht Games,
es ist nicht Mixed Reality,
sondern es ist, korrekt,
wie viele andere neue Technologien auch,
ist VR natürlich in diesem Segment
am allerbeliebtesten.
Man kann es auch kombinieren
mit beliebigen Sachen, okay, ja.
Aber da ist VR tatsächlich schon angekommen,
und das ist nicht jetzt verwunderlich,
weil wenn man sich mal
in die Vergangenheit guckt,
was Videos und DVDs
und solche Geschichten,
ich glaube wahrscheinlich auch die ersten,
wobei Blu-Ray weiß ich nicht,
aber die ersten Anfänge anguckt,
eines der ersten Branchen,
die da aufgesprungen sind
und da mitgemacht haben,
waren irgendwelche Porns.
Und dementsprechend,
ja, war das bei VR auch klar,
dass das dafür sofort am Start ist.
Das Ganze klappt
mit diesen beiden RGB-Kameras hier
und dem tiefen Sensor in der Mitte.
Im besten Fall sollte man nicht merken,
dass man ein Headset auf hat,
wenn man sich umguckt,
aber in der Realität fällt es dann doch deutlich auf.
Das Bild sieht etwas künstlich aus,
etwas pixellig,
und manchmal wobbelt es auch ein bisschen.
Aber es ist deutlich besser
als bei Quest 2, Quest Pro, Pico 4
und PlayStation VR 2.
Hier mal zum Vergleich
der gleiche Raum mit der Quest 2,
der Quest Pro und der Quest 3.
Meta gibt keine konkreten Spezifikationen an,
sagt aber,
dass das Path-Through-Bild
eine doppelt so hohe Auflösung hat
wie bei der Quest Pro
und eine zehnmal so hohe wie bei der Quest 2.
Außerdem ist das Bild farbig,
bei der Quest 2 war es noch schwarz-weiß.
Also ich muss sagen,
man kann beim aufgesetzten Headset
Text auf Displays ablesen,
also auf Computer, Monitor oder Smartphone.
Das ist im Alltag super praktisch,
wenn man manchmal schon irgendwas nachgucken will
und man dafür nicht das Headset absetzt.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Die große Frage allerdings,
wie schneidet die Quest 3 im Vergleich
zu Apples Vision Pro ab?
Leider konnte ich die Apple-Brille
noch nicht selbst ausprobieren,
Kollegen von mir aber schon.
Und Apple macht das Path-Through
offenbar noch einmal besser als Meta mit der Quest 3.
Wenn man das Headset aufhat,
das dauert vor noch ein paar Jährchen.
Ja, aber was kann man damit nun machen
mit diesem Path-Through?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viel.
Es gibt bislang erst wenige Apps,
die das unterstützen.
Eine sehr schöne ist von Meta selbst,
die ist kostenlos, heißt First Encounters
und da kommen dann so neckische Aliens aus der Decke.
Was ich ziemlich beeindruckend fand,
das System hat die Lampen in diesem Raum hier erkannt.
Das heißt, dass die echten Lampen
das künstliche Loch verdeckt haben.
Besonders cool,
dass man das direkt auf den Boden hat.
Ziemlich nice.
Ansonsten könnt ihr Browser-Fenster,
Videofenster etc.
in eurer echten Umgebung frei anordnen.
Also so ziemlich genau das,
was Apple auch bei den Vision Pro Demos gezeigt hat.
Ich stehe deshalb auch zu 100% zu meiner Aussage,
dass Quest 3 und Apple Vision Pro
exakt die gleiche Produktkategorie sind.
Die beherrschen die gleichen Funktionen,
auch wenn viele Leute sagen,
dass Apple ja nun was ganz anderes erfunden hat.
Es ist aber einfach nur so,
dass Apple weniger auf Spiele setzt
und mehr auf Produktivität.
Aber es wird für die Vision Pro auch Spiele geben
und für die Quest-Headsets
gibt es ja jetzt sogar schon Arbeitstools
wie Virtual Desktop oder Horizon Workrooms.
Ich bezweifle allerdings stark,
also Standort-
Können die denn auch wobbly Windows?
Weil ohne wobbly Windows ist das ja alles nix.
Heute, dass viele Menschen
den ganzen Arbeitstag
so ein schweres Headset auf dem Kopf haben wollen.
Das gilt sowohl für die Quest 3
als auch für die Vision Pro.
Meine Erfahrung ist,
dass es immer schlimmer ist.
Kopfschmerzen.
Ich bin aber wirklich gespannt,
wie das weitergeht.
Vielleicht täusche ich mich auch.
Achso, was aber halt wirklich auch
ohne jegliche Apps praktisch ist,
dass man mit der Quest 3
auch in 100% VR-Welten
mit einem Doppeltipp aufs Gehäuse
mal kurz die echte Welt einblenden kann.
Weil man zum Beispiel was trinken will
oder kurz mal nach der Katze gucken.
Verbesserung Nummer 2,
optische Qualität, Linsen und Display.
Die Fresnel-Linsen sind da nun
flache sogenannte Pancake-Linsen drin.
Der große Vorteil, die sind immer scharf.
Man muss also nicht wie bei der Quest 2
und ganz schlimm bei der Playstation VR 2,
die genau in der richtigen Position
vor den Augen haben.
Ich habe davon halt gar keine Ahnung.
Ich habe kein VR-Headset.
Nachteil von Pancake ist,
dass die Linsen mehr Licht schlucken.
Aber das ist meines Erachtens
bei der Quest 3 kein Problem.
Ich empfand das Bild immer als hell genug.
Durch die Pancake-Linsen
kann man sehr schön sehen,
wenn man das Gesichtspolster da mal abnimmt.
Leichter ist sie aber leider nicht.
Beide Headsets wiegen ungefähr ein halbes Kilo.
Was ebenfalls schnell auffällt,
die Auflösung ist ein ganzes Stück höher.
Pro Auge 2064 mal 2208 Pixel
statt wie bei der Quest 2
1832 mal 1920.
Die PSVR 2 hat auch weniger als die Quest 3,
nämlich 2000 mal 2040.
Apples Vision Pro
ist aber nochmal eine ganz andere Sportart.
Die zeigt jedem Auge
ein halbes Kilo mehr Pixel.
Die Quest 3 hat allerdings nur LC-Displays,
d.h. schwarz ist eher dunkelgrau
und auch die Farben kommen nicht so knallig rüber
wie z.B. auf der PSVR 2 mit OLED.
Dennoch, der visuelle Eindruck
auf der Quest 3 ist super.
Das Sichtfeld der Quest 3 ist auch gut.
Etwas besser als bei der Quest 2
und fast so gut wie bei der PSVR 2
und der Valve Index,
aber noch nicht perfekt.
Man hat also immer noch
einen leichten Klo-Rollen- oder Fernglas-Effekt.
Es ist also nicht das komplette...
...Sichtfeld ausgefüllt.
Das schafft aber bislang kein...
Hätte ich einen richtig nice Anwendungszweck für mich,
ich hätte so einen Teil schon.
Aber ich habe seit den Jahren,
auch seit dem Hype, wo es den da drum gab,
nichts gefunden für mich, wo ich gesagt hätte,
oh ja, dafür lohnt sich das richtig.
Consumer Headset.
Was ebenfalls beim optischen System verbessert wurde,
ihr könnt den Augenabstand jetzt stufenlos einstellen.
Bei der Quest 2 gab es nur drei Stufen,
außerdem ist der Abstandsbereich größer.
Für Simracing...
Okay, Chat, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Bestimmt auch DCS oder so was.
Flugsimulator-Kram.
Das ist bestimmt auch mega.
Aber nachdem ich beides nicht spiele.
50 mm bis 75 mm.
Das heißt, das Headset kann auch von Leuten getragen werden,
die einen ungewöhnlichen Augenabstand haben.
Ich persönlich bin da super durchschnittlich unterwegs.
Ich habe genau den weltweiten Männerdurchschnittswert
von 65 mm.
Allerdings bin ich stark kurzsichtig,
weshalb ich eine Brille tragen muss.
Und das geht mit der Quest 3 genauso gut oder schlecht
wie bei den Vorgängern.
Also es geht, aber ich finde es unangenehm,
weil da immer irgendwas rumwackelt
und weil man auch immer Angst hat,
dass man die Gläser zerkratzt.
Ich würde deshalb so Dioptrien-Einklicklinsen empfehlen.
Die werden ab demnächst von Meta selbst vertrieben.
Da kommen die dann von der amerikanischen Firma Zenni.
Oder ihr könnt die auch beim deutschen Hersteller
VR Optica bestellen.
Oder VR Optician, wie die Chinesen heißen.
VR Optica.
Verbesserung Nummer 3.
Mehr Rechenleistung.
Die Quest 3 ist wie alle Quests ja ein Standalone-Headset.
Habe ich ja schon gesagt.
Es läuft also autark ohne angeschlossenen Rechner.
Denn es ist ja wie gesagt ein Rechner eingebaut.
Also ein Android-Mobilsystem.
Und statt dem System-on-a-Chip Qualcomm XR2 Gen 1
steckt da nun ein XR2 Gen 2 drin.
Hat auch ein bisschen mehr RAM.
8 GB statt 6.
Und da man auf Quest-Headsets beliebige Android-Apps
sideloaden kann, haben wir mal...
Ja, das ist natürlich wirklich ein Vorteil.
Gerade wenn man basteln will,
ist so ein Android-System unten drunter
immer nice.
...in 6 installiert.
Da kommen bei der Quest 3 1706 Multicore-Punkte raus
und bei der Quest 2 1470.
Das ist ziemlich wenig,
was aber vermutlich daran liegt,
dass das Geekbench-Fenster ja
in einer detaillierten VR-Umgebung angezeigt wird.
Das heißt, das System nutzt den Großteil
der Rechenleistung fürs Umgebungs-Rendering
und nicht für Geekbench.
VR-Apps können dagegen ja die gesamte Leistung abrufen.
Schaut man sich allerdings Quest-2-Spieler an,
die an Quest 3 angepasst wurden,
wird die zusätzliche Grafik-Power sehr deutlich.
Hier zum Beispiel Red Matter 2,
links Quest 2, rechts Quest 3.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gibt es einen Unterschied.
Super deutlich zu erkennen.
Und auch in den Menüs ist die Schruptizität klar höher.
Meta hat um es angekündigt,
dass mindestens 50 vorhandene Spiele
an die Quest 3 angepasst werden
und es 50 neue Titel mit Quest-3-Support geben wird.
Kritikpunkte.
Es gibt aber auch ein paar nicht so schöne Dinge.
Zum Beispiel die Akkulaufzeit.
Mehr Leistung bedeutet auch mehr Leistungsaufnahme,
weshalb die Quest 3 in unseren Tests
oft nach weniger als 2 Stunden
die Quest 3 angepasst hat.
Ich finde, 2 Stunden am Stück
geht eigentlich voll klar für so ein Teil.
Länger willst du es wahrscheinlich
eh nicht am Stück aufhaben.
Hat eine Idee länger durchgehalten.
Außerdem, und das liegt wohl am kleinen Gehäuse,
die Quest 3 wird wärmer.
Richtig schlimm fand ich das nicht,
aber ja, merkte man schon.
Und in beiden Headsets steckt ein kleiner Lüfter,
den nimmt man in VR nicht so richtig wahr,
ist aber bei der Quest 3
definitiv etwas ausgeprägter zu hören.
Richtig unbefriedigend finde ich
die großen angekündigten Titel
wie Assassin's Creed Nexus VR,
Asgard's Thrasht 2,
Ghostbusters und Stranger Things
sind alle noch nicht erhältlich.
Schön wenigstens,
das umfangreiche Rollenspiel Asgard's Thrasht 2
bekommen alle gratis,
die eine Quest 3 kaufen.
Achso, die mehr als 1000 Quest 1 und 2 Apps
laufen natürlich auf der Quest 3
und wer die gekauft hat,
muss die nicht nochmal kaufen.
Und klar, um Apps zu kaufen
Das ist aber nett.
Moment, da gibt es unterschiedliche Accounts?
Es gibt ein Meta-Account
und ein Facebook-Account
ist nicht automatisch ein Meta-Account?
Ohne Meta-Account geht nichts.
Und ihr müsst euch darüber im Klaren sein,
dass wenn ihr Mixed Reality nutzt,
eure Umgebungstaten,
also die groben Punktwolken eures Raums,
in die Cloud geschickt werden
und dass darauf auch die Apps zugreifen können,
die Mixed Reality unterstützen.
Das wird benötigt,
aber wenn ihr in Raum arbeiten oder spielen wollt,
dann braucht die App die Raum-Info.
Ihr könnt das deaktivieren,
dass das Zeugs in der Cloud landet,
dann funktionieren aber alle diese Multi-User-Sachen nicht mehr.
Achso, und Meta hat wieder
keine ordentlichen Kopfhörer eingebaut.
Die Tonausgabe kommt nach wie vor
aus diesem kleinen Schlitz hier
und klingt zwar etwas besser als bei der Quest 2,
aber schön ist das trotzdem nicht.
Zumindest gibt es eine Klinkenbuchse,
da könnt ihr dann einen Kabelkopfhörer anschließen.
Bluetooth geht zwar in der ...
Klinkenbuchse?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das 2023 noch gibt.
Das wurde ja vor ein paar Jahren
von allen Herstellern abgeschafft.
Klinkenbuchse ist outdated, overrated.
Keiner hat eine Klinkenbuchse dran.
Klinkenstecker.
Dabei ging das für gefühlt 50 Jahre oder so ganz gut.
Und es ist ja nicht so,
dass das irgendwie schlecht wäre,
aber es hat den Herstellern wahrscheinlich nicht so gepasst,
dass man einfach alles dran anschließen kann,
was man will.
In der Theorie, aber in der Praxis
hat das eine viel zu lange Verzögerung.
Die Quest 2 wird serienmäßig
mit einem ergonomisch völlig unbrauchbaren Kopfband ausgeliefert.
Das schneidet nicht nur so ein hier an der Seite und an den Ohren,
sondern tut auch ganz schnell an der Stirn weh.
Wenn man das Teil einigermaßen regelmäßig verwenden will,
braucht man einen starren Kopfriemen,
der das Gewicht besser verteilt.
Meta verkauft das als Elite-Strap für happige 80 Euro,
aber es gibt auch Dritt-Anbieter, die sowas verkaufen.
Jedenfalls verstehe ich nicht, warum Meta ...
Kann man nicht erwarten,
das ist jetzt nicht ultra teuer,
aber trotzdem teuer,
weil da nicht so viel Scheißes Gummiband oder was auch immer dabei ist,
dass man das benutzen kann.
Was Headset nicht direkt mit einem brauchbaren Kopfriemen anbietet.
Fazit.
Bevor mein Fazit kommt, hier mal kurz der Eindruck
von meinem Kollegen Jan-Philipp Wöbbelking,
der die Quest 3 fürs CT-Parazin und Heise online getestet hat.
Also nachdem ich jetzt die Quest 3 ein paar Tage ausprobiert habe,
ist es wirklich schwer, wieder zur Quest 2 zurückzukehren,
weil das Bild ist halt noch mal eine ganze Ecke klarer und schicker
und durch diese Pancakelinsen ist sie halt auch schön kompakt.
Ja, und natürlich, was auch faszinierend ist,
ist einfach mal diese AR-Modi und AR-Spiele auszuprobieren
oder Mixed Reality,
auch wenn das oft halt noch wie ein Gimmick wirkt.
Das ist halt das Ding, das ist cool
und es hat so ein richtiger Wow-Effekt.
Das Problem ist,
das verliert ganz schnell die Begeisterung da dran.
Das probierst du mal eine Woche lang immer mal wieder aus
und dann startest du es nie wieder.
Und sollte Meta in Zukunft auch noch mehr bringen in der Richtung.
Hast du auch einen Kritikpunkt an der Quest 3?
Ist dir auch was Negatives aufgefallen?
Ja, also der Akku, der ist wahnsinnig schnell leer.
So schon in unter zwei Stunden.
Ja, muss da wieder an die Ladestation.
Und ja.
Ja, sehe ich alles ähnlich.
Die Quest 3 ist quasi in allen Belangen der Quest 2 überlegen.
Lediglich die Akkulaufzeit ist eine Idee kürzer.
Aber ich hatte ja schon am Anfang gesagt,
dass man eigentlich eh nach spätestens einer Stunde
eine Pause machen will.
Zumindest für mich passt das also.
Wenn ihr mit dem Gedanken spielt,
euch erstmals ein VR- beziehungsweise Mixed Reality-Headset zu kaufen,
könnt ihr auf jeden Fall zuschlagen.
Ihr kriegt zurzeit kein besseres Standalone-Headset.
als die Quest 3.
Wenn ihr eine Quest 2 habt,
würde sich ein Umstieg langfristig lohnen.
Das müsst ihr aber nicht überstürzen,
weil es zurzeit noch nicht wirklich viel
an die Quest 3 angepasste Software gibt.
Ja, und wenn ihr Apple-Fans seid
und sehr, sehr viel mehr Geld ausgeben wollt,
dann solltet ihr vielleicht auf die Vision Pro warten.
Die kann zwar in der grundsätzlichen Funktionalität
nicht viel mehr als die Quest 3,
aber ihr bekommt höhere Auflösung,
Augen- und Gesichtstracking.
Ich werde mir nach wie vor keine Karte geben.
Und die aufpolierte Apple-Experience.
Aber was ihr nicht kriegt,
und das kann es jetzt halt wirklich nur Meta bieten,
weder Apple noch Quest,
die haben halt in den letzten Jahren
eine Bibliothek mit über 1.000 Spielen und Apps aufgebaut.
Das ist meines Erachtens
das größte Alleinstellungsmerkmal.
Wenn ihr übrigens mehr und detailliertere Videos
zur Quest 3 und über VR-Albumen einsehen wollt,
Moment, Moment, was?
Was ist das für eine Spielekategorie?
Honoring Woman in VR.
What?
Ach, nein!
Sie ehren...
Das ist nicht die Spielekategorie.
Ich habe schon gedacht, was soll das sein?
Sie highlighten Spiele,
VR-Spiele von weiblichen Entwicklern.
Jetzt habe ich das gecheckt.
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine komische Game-Kategorie?
Ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal.
Wenn ihr übrigens mehr und detailliertere Videos
zur Quest 3 und über VR allgemein sehen wollt,
es gibt hier auf YouTube einige sehr kompetente,
deutschsprachige Leute,
die sich ausschließlich VR und MR widmen.
Zum Beispiel VoodooVR,
MRTV,
ZockstubeVR und MofranVR.
Kann ich euch ans Herz legen.
Guckt da mal rein.
Ich habe die Channel hier in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Ach so, ja, und gerne eure Meinung zu VR, MR
und dem ganzen Rest in die Kommentare schreiben.
Das hilft uns immer sehr herauszufinden,
was euch so interessiert.
Und gerne...
Also ich werde mir auch nach wie vor nichts kaufen.
Ich habe einfach keinen Anwendungszweck dafür.
Ich kann...
So cool ich Bastelsachen
und Technik finde,
so ganz ohne irgendwas,
was ich damit machen will,
macht es ja dann auch keinen Sinn,
sich das zu kaufen.
Kann ich das anklicken,
ohne dass da irgendwas Schlimmes passiert?
Okay.
Ja.
Beim Zug weiß man nie.
Hast du dir scheinbar einen Raspberry Pi bestellt.
Ab wann ist das denn vorbestellbar
oder bestellbar?
Ist das jetzt schon?
Berry Base, Berry Base,
das ist ja ein super Spiel.
Dann verstehe ich das.
Würde ich das machen,
hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch schon eins.
Aber mache ich ja nicht.
So, Raspberry Pi 6.
Gibt es denn den hier?
Pi 6.
Kam die noch gar keinen drinnen stehen?
Wollen wir mal Geizheiz.
Ach so, wir sind beim 5er,
nicht beim 6er.
Ups.
Wie komme ich auf Raspberry Pi 5?
Ach so, weil wir das Video gesehen haben.
Jaja, wir sind bei 5.
Raspberry Pi,
äh,
leider nicht verfügbar.
Ja, da habe ich ehrlich gesagt auch mit gerechnet.
Ab 23. Oktober.
Ja.
Dann warten wir mal ab, ne.
Raspberry Pi 5.
125 über 13.
Das ist ein 8G Modell trotzdem.
Nö, ich warte mal ab.
Ich meine, ich brauche keinen neuen Raspberry Pi.
Ich habe noch genug übrig hier.
Und ich habe auch keine Anwendungszwecke,
gerade für zusätzliche weitere Raspberry Pis.
Also insofern.
Mal abwarten.
Bevor du den holst,
schau das hier.
Was ist das?
Hey!
Das sind die mit dem Windows.
Mit diesem komischen Windows Tuning Pack.
Was ich sehr fragwürdig fande.
Nee, ich glaube nicht,
dass das eine sinnvolle Konkurrenz
für einen Raspberry Pi ist.
Und warum nicht?
Weil der Raspberry Pi nicht nur Hardware ist.
Der Raspberry Pi ist eine komplette Kombination
aus mehreren Dingern als Plattform.
Nämlich sehr viele Third-Party-Sachen,
die direkt beispielsweise
den GPIO-Pin-Header
unterstützen als Add-On.
Massive Tutorials,
super offizieller Linux-Support
und nicht irgendetwas halbherziges.
Also du wirst sicherlich
Hardware finden,
aber du wirst nicht
die für den gleichen Preis
oder ein bisschen mehr
oder ein bisschen weniger,
was auch immer,
deutlich performanter ist
oder vielleicht auch die deutlich
modernere Plattform ist,
was auch immer.
Aber die Kombination aus Ökosystem,
also aus der Hardware,
dem Preis und dem Ökosystem drumherum
ist der Raspberry Pi unschlagbar
und wird wahrscheinlich auch
der Fünfer in nächster Zeit
ein bisschen kompakter werden.
Ich meine, wir können ja mal reingucken,
was will er uns...
Ja guck mal,
allein schon der Formfaktor
kommt nicht hin.
Die Größe meine ich nicht,
aber da kannst du wahrscheinlich
nicht mal irgendwelche GPIO
Raspberry Pi-Add-Ons dranpappen,
gescheit.
Also wie gesagt,
da gehört mehr dazu,
als eine Hardware rauszubringen,
aber ihr könnt trotzdem mal gucken.
Das hier ist ein
Mini-PC,
der so groß ist wie ein Raspberry Pi,
doppelt so schnell ist
wie ein Raspberry Pi,
weniger kostet wie ein Raspberry Pi,
ja aber alles drumherum nicht hat,
was ein Raspberry Pi hat,
und upgradbar ist
mit PC-Express 2.0
und hier das Beste,
er zieht maximal 10 Watt im Betrieb,
eher eigentlich so 6 bis 8.
Rein ins Video,
also wie gesagt,
ich bin da äußerst skeptisch,
ich glaube nicht,
dass das eine sinnvolle
Raspberry Pi-Alternative ist,
aber guck,
ist ja gut jetzt,
wird ja viel zu laut.
Ist das,
das Ding sieht aus,
schau dir das an.
Wisst ihr wie es aussieht,
es sieht aus wie eine SSD-Verpackung,
die auch besonders fancy gemacht ist.
Dass du beispielsweise
sowas hier einfach anschließen kannst,
du hast beispielsweise so ein Modul,
das passt 1 zu 1
auf den GPIO-Header
vom Raspberry Pi drauf,
lässt dich draufstecken und gut ist,
und schon hast du auf einen Schlag
ein Relay, was du schalten kannst,
Analog-Digital-Konverter,
Digitale Inputs,
Outputs
und noch ein paar zusätzliche Sachen,
die durchgeschleift werden
vom Raspberry Pi.
Und das kannst du halt
mit vielen anderen Sachen
nicht so einfach machen,
dazu kriegst du eine fertige
Python-Library, die auf dem Raspberry Pi
gut läuft und gut integriert ist.
Wenn du sowas brauchst,
tun es halt andere Plattformen nicht.
Zumal ich gelesen habe,
dass der Raspberry Pi 5
sogar einen Analog-Digital-Konverter
mittlerweile auf den GPIOs
mit drauf hat.
Der glaube ich sogar offiziell
jetzt 3,3 Volt
tolerant ist.
War er ja meistens vorher auch schon,
aber offiziell nicht.
Oder umgedreht?
Das war der Raspberry Pi.
Der Raspberry Pi war ja oftmals
bei den GPIO-Pins
nicht 5 Volt tolerant.
Oder war das umgedreht,
die Geräte sind kaputt gegangen,
weil er 5 Volt standardmäßig hatte?
Ich glaube,
der brauchte 3,3 Volt
auf den GPIO-Pins.
Allein schon aus dem Grund
hast du halt,
das kannst du nur mit dem Raspberry Pi
gescheit machen.
Das hier
ist das SiMa Blade.
Was ist das SiMa Blade?
Der Nachfolger des SiMa Boards
kommt in dieser Verpackung.
Und das hier war das SiMa Board.
Hier haben wir den Vergleich.
Die erste Version
und die zweite Version.
Wo sind die Unterschiede,
was können sie?
Das Ding habe ich doch schon mal
gesagt, es gibt keine sinnvolle Alternative
zu einem Raspberry Pi.
Ich erinnere mich.
Das hier ist ein 8 Watt Mini-PC
mit PC-Express 2.0,
mit USB, Doppel Ethernet,
Display Out, Strom und das war's.
Hinten zwei SATA Anschlüsse.
Das Ding hat doch nicht mal
einen GPIO-Header, oder?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist überhaupt keine Alternative
zum Raspberry Pi.
Je nach Anwendungszweck vielleicht.
Aber dann ist der Anwendungszweck
wahrscheinlich auch nicht sinnvoll
geeignet für einen Raspberry Pi.
Nee, also
hat das ein GPIO-Output?
Ich habe jetzt
nichts erkannt.
Zumindest wahrscheinlich nicht
der PC-Express.
Du kriegst ja so ein Add-on-Board
gar nicht gescheit
in das Gehäuse rein.
Naja.
Also wie gesagt,
das ist eine richtig gute
Raspberry Pi-Alternative,
weil der Raspberry Pi
ein Gesamtsystem ist
aus Party-Sachen
und vor allem
super Linux-Support
und ganz viele Tutorials
und Anleitungen und Sachen
drumherum,
was man so mit anderen
Boards nicht kriegt.
Ich hatte ja mal den Vergleich.
Ich hatte mir ja mal
so einen Odroid
CPU-technisch
besser als
der Raspberry Pi,
aber ich habe es da gemerkt,
der Linux-Support,
nicht so, dass da Windows drauf
laufen würde oder so,
das gibt es nur mit Linux,
aber der Linux-Support war nicht
mal not even close,
wie gut das unter dem Raspberry Pi
funktioniert hat.
Du hattest da zig Probleme,
wir haben ja im Stream auch damit
rumgebaut, du hattest zig Probleme
zu kompilieren, dass es überhaupt
USB-Geräte erkannt hat
und das sind halt so Dinger,
die Sachen hast du im Raspberry Pi
einfach nicht.
Der geht in der Regel.
Ich denke nicht, dass das eine
sinnvolle Alternative ist.
Chat, ratet mal, was es bei mir
heute zu essen gibt.
Nudeln mit Lachs, korrekt?
Ihr habt recht,
Nudeln mit Lachs gibt es heute.
Und dabei,
also oben drüber,
haben wir Chinesen
Süß-Sauersauce,
weil so Nudeln mit Lachs
ohne was dabei, ist ja auch
ein bisschen trocken.
Moin Patrick, was für Nudeln?
Äh,
Moment,
die da, die da,
Fusilli,
ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht,
geschweige denn, ob es überhaupt
Italienisch ist oder irgendeine
deutsche Erfindung, die sich
ein bisschen China-Süß-Sauersauce
drauf und gut ist.
Reicht.
Ja, Spiralnudel, ne?
Das klingt,
das klingt schon sehr deutsch,
der Name.
Half-Life 2 RTX Remix.
So?
Ich will mal nur mal Graphics
angucken.
Und das jetzt mit RTX?
Also in meiner Erinnerung sah
Half-Life 2 genauso aus.
Okay, die Schattenwürfe
sind nicht schlecht.
Ich muss eh sagen,
Half-Life 2 ist von wann?
2004 oder so?
Äh,
was war das denn jetzt gerade?
Ich hab irgendwie den,
na geil,
den Verlauf aufgemacht,
wie auch immer das war.
Half-Life 2 Release Date?
Oder?
2004, ja.
Also ich finde,
Half-Life 2 ist wirklich gut
und ich glaube,
es gibt noch ein paar,
haben wir sogar schon ein paar von geguckt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Kenn ich, haben wir ein paar schon geguckt.
Ich glaub sogar die drei
haben wir schon geguckt, ja.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes,
was nicht so lang geht,
weil ich krieg langsam wirklich Hunger.
Bewachtes Klo,
what the fuck?
Was ist das?
Der teuerste Kopfhörer der Welt
im Test versus AirPods Max.
Die, die, die Mega-Apple-Fans
hier auf dem,
wobei, nee, dann verwechsel ich den Channel.
Da kommt doch bestimmt raus,
okay, Fazit wird sein,
die 70.000 Euro Kopfhörer
sind besser, aber nicht viel
und deswegen alle AirPods kaufen oder sowas.
Was wird es zu Essen geben?
Ja, was wohl?
Was könnte es wohl nur zu Essen geben?
Also das ist er nicht.
Der kostet das 10.000-fache weniger,
7 Euro.
Wieso wir diesen absurden Vergleich ziehen
und den Kopfhörer nicht kaufen?
Ach nur,
das ist, das ist aber schwach.
Nur den 5.000-Euro-Kopfhörer.
Das erfahrt ihr gleich.
Der HR1, der deutschen Firma Sennheiser,
ist unter Audiophilen
der Referenz-Kopfhörer schlechthin.
Auf YouTube fangen Tester
regelmäßig an zu weinen,
weil sie vom Sound-Erlebnis so ergriffen.
Okay, das ist, das ist,
das ist eben so Marketing-Shit.
Das ist, guck mal,
die Leute haben sogar bei Windows 11 geweint,
dann wahrscheinlich wegen anderen Sachen.
Aber laut Marketing natürlich,
weil sie so emotional mitgerissen waren.
Wir durften den HR1
als einer der wenigen eingeladenen Journalisten
aus der ganzen Welt
in der Sennheiser Manufaktur in Irland testen
und zeigen euch,
ob auch mir die Tränen in die Augen geschossen sind.
Also, worauf warten wir noch?
Das Ding müsste wahrscheinlich im Leben
keine 70.000 Euro kosten.
Das kostet 70.000 Euro,
um es noch,
das ist bestimmt irgendein 5-Fact-Marketing-Trick,
um das noch mehr Premium wirken zu lassen.
So, man hat halt einfach das Beste gebaut,
was man bauen konnte.
Hätte es dann entweder für
8.000, 9.000 oder 70.000,
da hat man einfach gesagt 70.000 Euro,
weil es sich noch mehr Premium anfühlt dann.
Also, ich gebe hier auch mal ganz gerne
für gute Hardware ordentlich Geld aus.
Aber 70.000 Euro für einen Kopfhörer,
näh.
Ich möchte,
dass ihr in diesem Video
wirklich ein Gefühl habt,
wie sich Kopfhörer für 70.000 Euro
klanglich von bezahlbaren Modellen unterscheiden.
Am besten mache ich das hier
gerade mit meinen 30 Euro.
Ach nee, Moment,
immerhin habe ich mein Biodynamics-Headset auf.
Das geht dann schon ein bisschen.
Was man da eigentlich mehr für sein Geld bekommt.
Und dazu müssen wir einfach mal ganz unten anfangen.
Auf der Suche nach dem günstigsten Schrott,
den man so auf dem Markt finden kann,
sind wir auf die Hama Slide gestoßen.
Und ich weiß, es klingt absurd,
aber dieser 7-Euro-Kopfhörer hier,
der soll für 70.000 Euro
gleich eine wichtige Sache verdeutlichen.
Schauen wir uns das Ding mal an.
Fällt auf, weniger Verarbeitung geht eigentlich nicht.
Dann kommt man eigentlich nur zu dem Schluss,
dass man jeglichen Anspruch an Musikgenuss aufgegeben hat,
wenn man diesen Dingern überhaupt irgendwas abgibt.
Vor allem sind das auch noch so On-Ear-Dinger,
die dann drücken nach einer Zeit.
Aber gut, 7 Euro,
kommt Hama nicht aus Bayern?
Wenn ihr aber bereit seid,
das Zehnfache auf den Tisch zu legen,
also 70 Euro,
da sind dann auch Leute,
die so 70.000 Euro für einen Kopfhörer ausgeben,
die haben dann auch vergoldete Ölbach-Kabel oder sowas.
Irgendwelche vergoldeten Klinke-Stecker
und so komisches Placebo-Zeug.
L-Headphones bieten Bluetooth,
Active Noise Cancelling,
Multipoint Connection,
Hands-Free Calls und Voice Control.
Ihr bekommt also viel mehr Funktion und Qualität
als beim 7-Euro-Kopfhörer.
Und man muss kein Audio-Feeler sein,
um zu verstehen,
warum Klänge immer noch etwas dröge klingen
und auch stimmgewaltige Tracks
bleiben einfach deutlich hinter den Erwartungen.
Wenn wir versuchen, die JBL preislich nochmal,
um, naja, nicht ganz das Zehnfache zu steigern,
dann trifft man auf die...
Man könnte auch einfach mal eine 0815,
keine Ahnung, irgendwas von irgendeinem AKG 701,
sonst was mit ganz normalem Kabel dran nehmen,
mal einen ordentlichen Kopfhörer-Verstärker anschließen
und ich wette,
die meisten Leute auch super krass
Hyper-Audio-Feeler,
hätten Probleme,
jetzt zu sagen,
bei einem Test,
welcher denn jetzt der bessere,
teurere Kopfhörer ist.
Kopfhörer haben alle ein bisschen
unterschiedliches Klangbild,
ja, das lasse ich mir gefallen,
aber es ist schwer,
da jetzt zu sagen,
okay, das ist der für 7.000,
das ist der für 400 Euro,
das ist der für 70.000.
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so einfach,
wenn natürlich das gescheit angeschlossen ist.
Fängt ja schon mit irgendwelchen
Noise-Canceling-Wireless-Dingern,
die nur alles Bluetooth,
was weiß ich,
3. irgendwas unterstützen,
an.
Also die wahrscheinlich nicht,
die sind wahrscheinlich besser,
aber man könnte sich einfach mal das nehmen,
vergleichen das mit irgendeinem gescheiten
Ding mit Kabel dran,
anschließen,
ich glaube, die meisten Leute
könnten es nicht auseinanderhalten.
Die meisten Leute,
ich kann nämlich,
ich will mich da jetzt nicht aufspielen,
ich bin besser oder so,
aber viele Leute empfinden
Badewannenklang als besser.
So nach dem Motto,
Badewannenklang ist halt sowas mit
Boosts in gewissen,
ein bisschen Bass-Boost,
ein bisschen Höhen-Boost,
vor allem Badewannen.
Und die denken,
das hat die richtig satter Sau,
das klingt richtig gut.
Ist dann egal,
aber klingt halt gut,
ist wahrscheinlich auch der einzige Grund,
warum Beats-Kopfhörer früher beliebt waren.
Und wenn man dann einen Kopfhörer hat,
der ein bisschen neutraler klingt,
da sagen viele,
das klingt so flach
und das ist so,
so hat er das wenig mitreißen
und sowas, wo ich mir denke,
ja gut, es kommt halt immer drauf an,
was man haben will,
so pauschal kann man das nicht sagen,
jeder hat ein bisschen andere Hörgewohnheiten.
Wenn man keine Kopfhörer aufsetzt,
wenigstens könnten den 70.000 Euro Kopfhörer da raushören.
Außerdem würde ich mir genau,
das kommt ja auch noch dazu,
Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer würde ich jetzt auch
gar nicht so sehr rein nach
high-endigster Soundqualität aussuchen,
sondern wie gut das Noise-Canceling ist
und wie easy die Bedienung ist vor allem,
weil du willst ja auch mal mit dem Knopfdruck
zum Beispiel Noise-Canceling einen ausmachen.
Ja, es ist alles,
es ist viel Geschmackssache dabei.
Es sind genauso wie die Leute,
die immer behaupten,
sie hören Audio prinzipiell nur unkomprimiert,
weil ihnen die Soundqualität von MP3 zu schlecht ist.
Ich weiß, wir haben sogar im Chat Leute,
die das immer behaupten,
aber es gibt Tests,
wo die Leute blind Audio-Files
haben vorgespielt bekommen,
komprimiert, unkomprimiert,
mittelmäßig gutes MP3, gutes MP3
und die Allermeisten konnten noch nicht mal
mittelmäßiges MP3 zu unkomprimiert unterscheiden.
Also da ist viel Einbildung dabei
in diesem Audiosektor.
Und es gibt ja auch noch mehr Sachen,
was Kopfhörer und Headsets unterscheidet.
Es gibt ja welche,
da hast du eher den Eindruck,
der Fachmann bei Kopfhörern nennt sich das dann
breite Bühne,
fragt mich nicht, wer sich das überlegt hat,
hat ja jeder Bereich,
hat ja so eigene Fachbegriffe,
bei Kopfhörern nennt sich das dann
breite Bühne.
Also sprich,
ja wie, wie, wie, wie,
schwer jetzt zu sagen,
wie gut kannst du verschiedene
Sachen noch rausholen,
wie breit hört sich das alles an.
Bei manchen hört sich das eher,
eher kompakt an,
bei anderen eben besonders breit.
Das gibt es nicht so pauschal,
das Ding und die meisten Leute,
behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal,
könnten es nicht unterscheiden.
Aber es gibt ja in diesem Bereich
ein geschlossener Kopfhörer,
der für viele qualitativ
schon sehr weit oben mitspielt.
Und absolut,
ich weiß die Airpods Max sind nicht günstig,
aber sie bieten ein gutes Gesamtpaket
aus Design, Tragekomfort
und natürlich einer sehr guten Audioqualität.
Das Aluminium,
Textilgewebe und die gummierten Bügel
wirken darüber hinaus einfach deutlich hochwertiger
als der Kunststoff bei den JBL.
Nun will ich euch aber erklären,
warum wir diese seltsamen
Komponenten herstellen.
Was die Qualität angeht,
als auch das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis.
Wir hätten hier auch die Sony XM5 gezeigt.
Das stimmt schon.
Es ist ein Riesenunterschied
zwischen einem super billigen
5 Euro
Amazon Basics Kopfhörer
oder irgendwas für 50, 60 Euro
von einem halbwegs kompetenten Hersteller.
Also was eine ganze Zeit lang
so ein Geheimtipp war
an günstigen Kopfhörern,
wie z.B. die Boxdinger.
Das ist glaube ich der Hersteller,
der normalerweise,
ich bin mir nicht sicher,
für Sennheiser oder für Beyer Dynamics
die Kopfhörer hergestellt hat.
Bin mir nicht sicher,
ob das noch so ist.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren so.
Und die waren eine zeitlame
richtige Preis-Leistungs-Empfehlung immer.
Die waren günstig
und für den Preis wirklich nice.
Für um die 300 Euro
und hätten ebenfalls
ein 5 Euro JBL Kopfhörer.
Und das ist wichtig zu verstehen,
denn ihr werdet gleich merken,
dass die eigenen Erwartungen
an viel teurere Kopfhörer
eigentlich gar nicht erfüllt werden können.
Denn das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis
wächst eben nicht proportional mit.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Das hier ist der Focal Utopia
für 5.000 Euro.
Die haben doch auch Boxen, oder?
Focal, die haben doch so geschwungene,
so geschwungene Boxen haben die doch.
Ja, die Dinger.
Die auch irgendwie...
Also man kann es auch echt übertreiben, Mann.
Tja.
Einfach ein bisschen Kohle ausgeben.
Wer hat nicht mal eine Viertel Million
um sich ein bisschen Audio-Equipment zu kaufen?
Bestellen und dann wieder zurückschicken.
Und auch unter audiophilen Fans
ist das hier kein Schnäppchen mehr.
Aber wenn er so viel teurer ist,
dann muss er doch auch wirklich
viel mehr auf dem Kasten haben, oder?
Naja, also lass es mich so erklären.
Dem Kunden, der sich für ein solches Modell interessiert,
der fährt natürlich damit keine U-Bahn,
sondern genießt die Dinger zu Hause
im doppelt so teuren Ledersessel.
Der Kopfhörer muss also auch kein Active Noise Cancelling
oder sowas mitbringen.
Im Gegenteil.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt braucht er das wirklich nicht.
Wenn ich mir einen Kopfhörer kaufe,
um da mit Musik zu hören oder am PC anzuschließen,
der ist sogar hinderlich, wenn er Noise Cancelling hat.
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Produktkategorien.
Ich kaufe dafür gar nicht.
Da gebe ich ihm voll recht.
Also es gibt super Kopfhörer im Bereich von 150 bis 300 Euro.
Da fährst du preisleistungsmäßig richtig gut dabei.
Und es gibt auch richtig gute Preis-Leistungssachen
für unter 50 Euro.
Hinten finden sich vor allem in diesem Preissegment
offene Bauweise.
Im Gegensatz zu den AirPods Max kann man das gut zeigen.
Die Hörmuschel der AirPods sind komplett geschlossen.
Das Aluminium ist dicht.
Schallwellen kommen also schlechter rein, aber auch raus.
Die Utopia sind geöffnet.
Die Muschel ist perforiert.
Der Schall hat also frei.
Das ist daheim natürlich sinnvoll,
wenn du noch was mitbekommen willst von deiner Umwelt.
Wenn du hören willst, dass das Telefon klingelt
oder dass DHL da ist
oder dass einer aus dem Erdgeschoss was ruft,
ist das nicht verkehrt.
Natürlich hören die Leute drumherum auch ein bisschen mehr.
Aber das ist, je nachdem wo man sitzt,
gar nicht mal so wild.
Ich finde offene Kopfhörer,
oder es gibt ja auch halb-offene,
tatsächlich ganz angenehm daheim.
Jetzt habe ich gerade das MMX300 auf.
Das ist ja komplett geschlossen,
auch mit Ohr rein.
Da hörst du teilweise echt schwierig was,
gerade wenn man noch Musik laufen hat.
Freie Fahrt vom Ohr weg.
Zwar scheiden sich hier manchmal die Geister,
welche Bauweise jetzt die bessere ist.
Fakt ist aber,
der Schall strömt nach außen ab
und wird nicht von der Hörmuschelwand
wieder ins Ohr reflektiert.
Das führt auch dazu,
dass jeder im Raum mitbekommt,
was ihr auf einem offenen Kopfhörer gerade hört.
Aber so ist dieser doch
etwas massiv wirkende Kopfhörer
etwas leichter
und buchstäblich offener im Klang,
zugunsten der räumlichen Darstellung.
Und ja, diesen Unterschied kann man
auf jeden Fall wahrnehmen,
wenn ich behaupten würde,
dass ich Menschen kenne,
die den Unterschied eben nicht hören würden.
Aber mir persönlich präsentiert sich hier
einfach eine sehr offene Stelle.
Es gibt Leute,
die erkennen auch den Unterschied nicht.
Also ich denke,
es gibt Leute,
die zwischen 15 und 60 FPS nicht erkennen.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht
von 30 auf 60 gehen.
Es gibt Leute,
die erkennen 15 zu 60 nicht.
Es ist mir unbegreiflich,
wie das möglich ist,
dass man von geruckelt
zu superflüssig gehen kann
und Leute erkennen es nicht.
Aber das ist möglich, das gibt es.
Ja, sorry, ich habe ja vergessen,
das Auge sieht nur 12 FPS.
Ja, richtig, richtig.
Und das ist auch
ein guter Stelleneindruck.
Man sitzt als Zuhörer vor der Bühne
und kann die einzelnen Musiker
mit ihren Instrumenten orten.
Das funktioniert beim Fokal sehr gut.
Außerdem treten Stimmen mehr in den Vordergrund
und betrieben mit einem externen Kopfhörerverstärker
entfalten die Fokal auch einfach noch mal mehr Power
und eine viel höhere Lautstärke,
ohne klanglich dabei auszubrechen.
Aber klar, wer solche Kopfhörer kauft,
der spart am Ende auch nicht am Zubehör
und dann kann so ein Kopfhörerverstärker
hier auch schon mal 2.600 Euro kosten.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr,
wie soll ich sagen,
sehr viel Gefühl dabei.
Also natürlich hört man einen Unterschied
zwischen einem ganz billigen Verstärker,
der am besten auch noch wild anfängt
zu rauschen beim Einstöpseln irgendwo,
versus einem ganz guten.
Es gibt ja Leute,
die gehen so weit und sagen,
sie nehmen nur Verstärker mit Röhren drin
und sowas.
Da gibt es sehr viel Glaubenssachen
und aber wie gesagt,
ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt
und einem gewissen Qualitätsniveau,
95% der Leute
können auch nicht mal mehr Mittel
zu gut unterscheiden.
Also diese Kopfhörer richten sich
natürlich an Menschen,
die den Unterschied hören können
und auch wollen.
Und das gelingt am besten,
wenn man sie direkt miteinander vergleicht.
Und deswegen haben wir die Focal
auch mitgenommen nach Irland
in die Manufaktur,
wo von einem deutschen Hersteller
die teuersten Kopfhörer
der Welt hergestellt wurden.
Ah, ok, guck,
der hat auch Röhren
als Verstärker.
Also eben im Verstärker.
Da gibt es ja welche,
die schwören da total drauf.
Vergesst alles,
was ihr über gute Verarbeitungsqualität
zu glauben wisst.
Vergesst alles über perfekten Klang.
Eins kann ich schon mal vorweg nehmen,
der Sound aus den HI1
war das Beste,
das jemals auf meine Ohren getroffen ist.
Los!
Zuallererst muss man das prunkvolle Stück
aus seinem Dornröschenschlaf befreien.
Fast wie bei einem Ritual
fahren zuerst die Bedienelemente
aus dem von einem Steinmetz
gefertigten massiven Block Marmor heraus.
Da sieht man mal,
da wird sehr viel Bullshit mitverkauft, Mann.
Daraufhin machen sich
acht Röhrenverstärker auf den Weg,
sich aus einem Sockel zu schieben,
um sich in Position...
Es ist natürlich enorm wichtig,
dass mein Verstärker in einem Block sitzt,
um mich in Position zu bringen.
Anschließend glühen die einzelnen Röhren auf.
Denn tatsächlich dient dieser andauernde Moment dazu,
dass sich die Vorverstärker aufwärmen,
um ihre optimale Betriebstemperatur
erreichen zu können.
Anschließend öffnet sich die magische Schatulle,
in der die HI1 aufgebettet...
Dass sie aufwärmen müssen ist bei Röhren,
das ist tatsächlich normal, ja.
...gebracht werden.
Und auch hier wird die Zeit genutzt,
um den Kopfhörer aufzuladen,
denn schließlich handelt es sich beim HI1
um einen elektrostatischen Kopfhörer.
Und das ist das Ergebnis.
Das ist alles so weit weg vom Konsumereinheitsbrei,
den wir uns leisten können.
Aber dient es am Ende dazu,
einfach davon abzulenken,
dass der HI1 womöglich am Ende genauso klingt
wie jeder andere hochwertige Kopfhörer?
Die Antwort lautet nein.
Denn zum einen dient dieser ganze Vorlauf
keinem Ablenkungsmanöver,
sondern ist Teil der technischen Aufwärmphase.
Naja, ein bisschen auch.
Ein bisschen, oh, wir erleben jetzt gleich was ganz Tolles
und so ist ja da auch schon dabei.
Also, und des Erlebnisses,
der den Musikgenoss hier vollumfänglich begleitet.
Darüber hinaus würde ich den HI1
einfach als kompromisslos beschreiben.
Es wäre jetzt vermessen zu behaupten,
dass ich schon mal einen Kopfhörer...
Nein, nein, nein, das würde ich mir nicht kaufen.
Wie gesagt, ich gebe Geld,
ich gebe gerne Geld aus für ordentliche Hardware,
aber ich gucke immer noch drauf,
dass man irgendwie was für kriegt.
Ich kaufe mir nie sinnlos einfach nur was.
...Kopfhörer auf den Kopf hatte,
der einfach besser klingt.
Ich würde es so beschreiben,
dass das Video vielen die Möglichkeit,
jedes Instrument auf der Bühne herauszuhören
und räumlich einzuordnen.
Darüber hinaus war er auch vom Bass perfekt abgestimmt
und einfach eine Wohltat für die Ohren.
Aber es gibt ein Aber
und das setzt genau da an,
wo wir vorhin aufgehört haben.
Das Ding ist halt,
selbst wenn ein Kopfhörer
sich nicht exakt perfekt anhört,
wie man es jetzt gerne hätte,
dann ist die beste Variante nicht.
Man sucht einen Kopfhörer,
der sich dann exakt immer so anhört,
was je nach Musik
oder Anwendungszweck unterschiedlich ist,
sondern man dreht einfach ein bisschen dran rum
an den Settings,
also nicht vom Kopfhörer,
sondern an der Player-Software oder sonst wo
und stellt das halt ein bisschen ein.
Wenn man ein bisschen zu viel Bass hat,
macht man halt ein bisschen
die unteren Frequenzen runter.
Da würde ich nicht die Kopfhörer wechseln für.
Außerdem ist es einfach so,
dass ich mich nicht so gut fühle.
Außerdem, aus irgendwelchen Gründen
stehen ja viele Leute auf so Badewanne beim Sound.
Wir haben natürlich bewusst
diese verrückten Preissprünge gemacht,
um zu verdeutlichen,
dass das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis
am Anfang echt rapide zunimmt,
dann abflacht und am Ende
eigentlich gar nicht mehr
im finanziellen Verhältnis steht.
Aber natürlich klingen die HI1 annähernd perfekt,
aber nicht um 65.000 Euro besser
als die Focal Utopia
und die wiederum nicht mehr
im finanziellen Verhältnis.
Da schlägt man einfach
die berühmten 80% Leistung,
die ja schon sehr ordentlich sind.
Bis dahin sind Qualitätssprünge
auch oft noch nachvollziehbar,
aber für die letzten 20%
zahlt ihr dann einfach teilweise
ein Vielfaches mehr.
Und so ist es auch bei den HI1.
Sie sind natürlich die besten Lautsprecher,
die ich je auf meinem Kopf hatte,
aber sie sind keine Quantensprünge
von anderen sehr hochwertigen Kopfhörern entfernt.
Und nein, sie haben mir auch
ein bisschen zu viel gesagt.
Das ist vor allem irgendein Marketing-Bullshit.
Ich verstehe auch nicht,
warum das heute so beliebt ist
für irgendwelche Marketing-Sachen,
dass die Leute vor Emotionen
immer gleich anfangen müssen zu heulen.
Bei fucking Windows 11
haben die auch fast geheult.
Die heulen wegen dem Preis wahrscheinlich.
Es ist einfach nicht so,
dass man da jetzt etwas Magisches hört.
So, dass man wirklich das Gefühl hat,
oh mein Gott, das ist doch gar nicht möglich.
Fakt ist,
die HI1 und der HI1
bieten einen unvorstellbaren Klang.
Sie beeindrucken, absolut.
Aber sie lassen euch nicht glauben,
dass ihr etwas Übermenschliches hört.
Und dieser Eindruck
wird mir von vielen YouTube-Testern,
audiophilen Magazinen und einigen Experten
einfach zu oft vermittelt.
Die HI1 sprechen einfach ein sehr besonderes,
exklusives Ideal ab.
Das bedeutet aber nicht,
wenn ihr euch die Teile nicht leisten könnt
fürs eigene Wohnzimmer,
dass ihr vielleicht was Großartiges verpasst.
Die sind selbstverständlich
aufgrund ihres ganz anderen Einsatzgebietes
natürlich auch viel alltagstauglicher.
Rackman, da gebe ich dir recht.
Man muss einfach nur mal gucken,
was sie in einem ordentlichen Audio-Studio haben.
Da ist nichts mit Marmorplatten aus Steinmetz
und irgendwelchen Goldplatinen,
Goldveredelten, sonst wie Kabeln.
Da ist einfach ganz solides,
high-end Studio-Equipment am Start.
Das ist nicht billig,
aber das sind keine 70.000 Euro Kopfhörer.
Euch irgendwie zu vermitteln,
was ihr verpasst...
Also in Studios sehr beliebt
vor einer ganzen Weile
waren unter anderem sowas wie
Bayerdynamics DT 990 oder 770
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Als wir hören mal mit,
wie die Aufnahmen sind.
Das sind Kopfhörer im Bereich von
150 bis 350 Euro.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
was ein DT 990 zur Zeit kostet.
Ja.
Also wenn es so Dinger
für ein Audio-Studio tun...
...nicht verpasst habt,
wenn ihr eben niemals in den Genuss kommt,
solche Kopfhörer wirklich mal zu hören.
Okay.
Aber hopp, das ist der Ende.
Aber kein schlechtes Video.
Chat-Key, ich habe Hunger.
Geh jetzt was essen.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Wait.
Vielleicht hören wir uns heute Mittag nochmal
und wir gucken uns
die sechste Season von Battlefield 2042 an.
Weil auf MW3 halte ich geistig aus.
So, also bis dann Leute.
Macht's gut.
See you.